a lot of you have asked for this person
to be on the show but a lot of you have
asked this question how come you never
do anything with cookies how come you
never ever ever have done an interview
with Burner how come you guys don't do
cookies reviews I've never seen cookies
in any of your videos Thomas You' never
even been to the store you know what now
that I think about it do these fools not
like each
[Music]
other
perfect
[Music]
perfect that was different I don't know
if they heard that but that was
different what's up guys uh this is the
dope as usual podcast my name is Thomas
dope as Yola whatever you want to call
me I'm with my co-host Marty O'Neal up
guys what's up it's a solo episode we're
back the teacher out of the room we're
allowed to say whatever we want today's
episode is uh I don't know it's December
I was thinking 2024 like I'm a full
grown adult now I'm about to be Twilight
Zone age when all the so it's getting
close I got to stop beating around the
bush and going well I don't want to you
know make somebody upset or I don't want
to say this or say that so this episode
is all
[Music]
about now Marty's a giant this episode
is all about getting things off getting
things out there just being done because
at the end of the day I really don't
care it's not going to affect my every
day I don't care it's just something
that when it's brought up a lot like
what you going just say like no not
going to happen probably you know so
today's episode I'm G leave you a little
intrigued we'll get into that in a
second all right we'll get into that in
a second before we want to say guys the
podcast channel is monetized again thank
you very much it just came back kind of
yeah you just said you apply go
apply okay all right so this episode
we're trying not to get age restricted
every episode for the past couple week
been age restricted but we're just
trying our best guys and either way go
listen on Spotify if you were in the car
and if you only listen to music and go
God I don't know what to listen to
listen to the podcast listening to
podcast passes the time so well I met
somebody at the hash hole event and they
said dude I do 12 hours stock room flies
by that's what it's there for yeah
that's exactly what sh out to everybody
and we posted our Spotify stats Finland
Sweden weing Inland all
our new listener stats are all the top
countries are in Europe shout out
everybody in Europe listening to the
show all right all right rolling your
spliffs smoking your hash thank you guys
appreciate you yeah Spotify shout out to
Spotify thank you very much we
appreciate you for putting us out there
showing us to everybody in Europe and
now some of our top listeners are
European countries which is very cool
they looked at Marty and went oh
home that's what they said like when ET
what does he do he sees like something
on TV and he points to home what was it
that's what happened I'm not calling you
aliens I'm sorry you know you know what
you're in for if you're listening you're
here all right um we're monetized again
also the clips channel is doing very
well thank you very much dope as usual
podcast Clips thank you guys for
following everything also we did a
giveaway on the Instagram so go ahead
and follow our Instagram dope as usual
podcast and our Twitter dope as usual
podcast also our Tik Tok dope as usual
podcast um about to hit 100K about to
hit 100K thank you very much guys we did
a giveaway on Instagram drop your
favorite product uh we had one person
win thousands of comments 20,000 likes
on this post across the board thank you
guys thank you guys very much we'll do
much more of that we realize when we do
a giveaway it's like okay 20,000 people
like this that means
19,999 people are going to be slightly
disappointed that they didn't win this
but we're going to keep just trying to
roll the stuff out more often yes so
thank you very much we appreciate you
guys for checking all our socials and uh
we're just giving you the updates we're
about to get into some stuff trying to
give it a little buffer all right but if
you're here today's the day probably a
lot of questions asked I mean questions
answered today um you just answered one
of your most alltime asked questions on
the latest video on the dope as YOLO
channel right did the math broke it down
oh H how much do have I smoked in my
life it was like 680 LBS or something
yeah you're like it's not that much it's
it isn't when you think about it like oh
you smoke that much you do this for a
living blah blah blah 600 yeah I guess
that's a lot probably closer to seven or
eight yeah it's probably a lot I think
it's a lot in the end but like it's
not we don't know go watch the video oh
it hasn't dropped yet oh [__] oh oh oh
sorry the video hasn't dropped yet yeah
it's about to drop the day after this
episode comes out so um it's almost
Christmas time guys lot of stuff
happening um yeah we're getting getting
let's get into it cam had a game this
morning I didn't tell you what happened
we were out there at the ass crack of
dawn at this game and something got into
Cam today boy I don't know what it was
soon as the game kicked off I'm like oh
he's moving a little different he
something's something's going on within
the first minutes of the game boom boom
blasted in not even like oh sometimes
kids will kick it and it's like oh I
went in he scored send it in with
Authority off top they get the ball back
all right good shot Camp couple of two
plays later same thing takes the [__]
come down boom blast right in the N yeah
we're talking about 9:00 a.m. this
morning Ken two goals back to back now
the other team shook moments later comes
back down does the other thing same
thing
boom Patrick in the first quarter he
took their souls from I told him I'm
like bro you took a couple ankles you
took the whole team Soul Souls that's
they're not even 10 he had him shook he
took their souls he did they were all
faking injuries they wanted the game to
be over fake injury in soccer those kids
all they get hurt like a video game
every time they go down they're grabbing
their knees and riding around in pain
and then they're fine like moments later
yeah and that's what happens when your
kid it hurts real bad at the beginning I
remember being on the ground going ah
and the sideline coach you're right now
yeah someh am yeah heard a lot back then
you think I'm lying F I'm starter I want
to play yeah hell yeah good for cam wow
it was cool it was cool his coach right
before it happened his basketball coach
walked out to me game is his big ass
trophy cuz they they won his basketball
team won first place oh but he had a
soccer game during the stupid basketball
game he had his soccer
championship one those chose football we
did basketball in the morning and then
we had to do soccer so we did both that
day but he missed the championship game
so he got this big Deon
Sanders cam Sanders out here right
that's cool that's a sick ass name um so
Mar's having his fourth kid guess he he
h April talked about it after the last
episode right before we started Mar said
April's so violently mushroom type high
off the weed the second that they left
the episode last week and I don't know
what it is I haven't smoked at all today
I feel so did we eat Edibles last night
no oh yeah I smoked a lot last night
maybe that's why I feel like this oh
yeah you went through your whole stash
right yeah no I
organized but I smoked so many hash but
you went to the event I'd imagine you
got two nights ago yeah okay last night
I'm talking about last night I don't
know what happened I guess what was the
coolest thing you got at the event oh
just got a bunch of hash holes that
we're about to start smoking how long we
been
here not close enough not even close hey
guys if we look a little better uh three
years into this thing we made a slight
adjustment sometimes I'm real when we
say blown out it's like white washed out
you're blown out you're washed out
light's too bright light is too bright
on my skin you ever notice like
sometimes I like damn times you look
especially with the smok in air yeah you
need some sleep bro you look pale are
you okay there's a lot of times I go I
look
sick it's cuz this light I'm
Marty let's point the light up and
reflect off the white pain tilted 15
degrees we tilted it from
here to here changed the entire of room
the whole room now this shots deeper and
darker nicer nice contrast and all these
angles this is nicer cuz you were lit
differently than all the other angles
I'm really like yeah cuz you guys are
nice you guys are they're nice and I'm
just I'm getting blasted with light over
here so we're good now guys we wanted to
uh we're we're treading lightly because
we're about to get into it all right
this episode once again we're po we're
recording on a Saturday this has to be
turned over in one day guys just what it
is it's hard to get guess in December
when people are going with their
families I thought we were going to get
E4 in here today didn't happen without
getting 40 just didn't happen today when
he's in town he's in town when he's got
time he's got time and when it happens
it happens took many took a a year and a
half [__] three years let's let's
just you know when it happens it happens
we're stoked it's
awesome it's cool are you guys
ready also it's been it's December M
next year I mean next month is the end
of the season I was thinking drop it in
the comments what do you think do you
think putting seasons on our show dates
us because you think season you
automatically think
year I guess the first year was not even
a year I first season was year it was
like 36 episodes yeah it was 30
something episodes
so what do you think do we should we
number them or should we season this and
every year the look changes and that's
how we know oh that was like year two oh
that's year three that's year four
that's year five to me it's like I never
thought about it by years it's kind of
by the sets it is almost like by that it
kind of goes by that like our our lease
is up we're about to get a new set guys
we're going to move so it's another
season but saying Seasons I feel dates
us like crazy well the reason why I
wanted to do it like that off top is so
that we could
like yeah like you could license these
Seasons out I get it I mean there's
going to be 52 episod I mean it's DEC
get up there quick January to December
it's pretty much like that that booklet
what do you guys think what would you
see cuz sometimes I see Rogue like
episode 2 th whoa mhm
yeah that's crazy that's a long time but
he does like three episodes a week yeah
and he's live and he's so it's different
they just put it out so you guys tell us
what do you think as podcast fans what
do you think is the best route I was
just thinking about it yesterday I don't
want it to be like damn season five you
guys been doing this for five years no
it's not been that long we've only had
like 150 episodes man so that's what I
was thinking
um
yeah are you ready MH CU I don't even
know what I don't know the details of a
lot of the [__] that we're about to get
into I don't think so much oh no you're
going first
oh you're going first cuz it's shorter
and if it's shorter we can smoke right
after mine's going to be very oh very
extensive cuz I talk a lot oh real quick
real quick OG modeled for our push trees
drop right looks so sick look check it
out push trees.com guys we did our high
fashion stuff like all Chenille patch
patches uh embroidery embroidery of the
collar long sleeve it looks elegant we
got slides with a dust bag it's all like
high high-end designer MH Stoner Weare
that's why we did it it's dop you can
wear it at the restaurants and go to
Morton be like oh yeah you can come in
you look nice D like yes some weed so
what I'm saying is we had OG do it cuz
it would look cool OG rocking the nice
designer [__] when I tell you that this
man was
19,000 times more scared than when he's
sitting right
here of OG might as well have been
shaking in his shoes and knees knocking
he was so embarrassed to take these
pictures all he was doing was smoking
weed on his own porch he lives at that
he's been for 25 years I said OG I want
to take the picture and he kept going
the backyard's nice bro and at the end I
went was that because you were
embarrassed a I didn't realize he kept
saying the backyard got good picture
like it's just grass why do you want
want us to go in the VAC so much I don't
get what why you keep pushing that
anytime we heard a neighbor door open he
just
stopped they go inside all right take it
hurry up you got one more you got one
more picture hurry
up I feel dumb I feel dumb he kept
saying it and neighbors were coming off
of work and he'd he get back into his
yard and he'd go back into his house
like wait like yo we're just smoke
because we had the big Flash thing two
tall ass white fools out there like 6'4
causing attention in East LA the Big
Flash thing and Lou our homie from the
UK the guy's accent and he's fing tall
and holding this flasher I get why he's
like but the more close cuz his mom
lives across the street from him the
closer we got across the street to
toward his mom's like eye view the more
like scared he got going like hurry up
you got you got one more picture bro
hurry up I was like OG stand there
you're not giving me one more picture if
I come over here to get not the picture
I wanted hurry up man I feel dumb you
look fine you're smoking a joint you're
just smoking a joint
you're I feel dumb all right hurry up
and we got the sickest pictures of the
whole shoot anyway so I just want to say
that before we started OG is so
frightened and it's cuz I think cuz he
had it's like when you bring your it's
like my son he's my son so when I bring
my son he's like oh hi and he gets to
school hey what's up man like trying to
act cool over here fol I know who you
are you [__] your pants when you were a
kid you used to [__] your pants like
that's how I feel like it's your
neighborhood man you're fine I just
thought it was so funny he was
like all right hurry up they gone go bro
they're just neighbors man it was great
it was I wish we could have recorded
that sorry for real that should have
been it was you missed the whole vlog
the whole shoot was that it was just
OG it was good I had OG in a polo in a
polo all right here we go guys thank you
so much for being here if you're he in
this episode this is what you're here
for we're about to get into some stuff
we're about to get into all the clips
you've been watching because this is a
this is one Marty's going to tell you a
story story time are you guys ready this
one you might have heard but you have no
idea what who the
circumstances this is season one you
talked about this when you were still on
the other side of the warehouse damn
near with a 40ft cable extension cable
yeah you were remote but in the same
building it's so crazy but the depth
behind you was was nice right [__] look
cool what if we just got a sick
warehouse and just filmed right in the
middle of
it the the sound might we could figure
that figure out we know what we're doing
now yeah just throw it out there you
guys
ready already take it away you know I'll
set it up
one time I've already kind of told this
story but you got to say it again and I
think you should start with what we're
talking about who we're talking about
because I don't know who this man is
until you said his name when the F
before we were we were getting ready for
an episode in season one and you told me
some of the story I went say that on the
podcast you went I don't know if I want
to stir anything up with the guy goes I
know he's like a social media dude and
go who
cares mhm and then what we say
who is he and then we looked it up and
go oh he's like he talks about a lot of
drama well here's some drama for him I
just think it's like lame so I'm like
put him on blast I don't care but it's
up to you then before this episode I
said Marty if I'm going to talk about
something you got to talk about
something and you oh so here we go Marty
you you could say it but I would go into
detail I would go into detail about what
happened why it happened then your
reaction like just like you told me then
what happened yeah yeah and then you
moved yeah go yeah I mean we kind of
already went over the story but I just
we didn't full detail like you never
talked about it say it like you never
talked about all right well I
mean we're so positive we're such a
positive show first of all this is dead
like this is not a thing this is just a
a relatable topic so I have something to
say this
episode look it we never talk about
drama stuff but this I think is a great
story that every time I see the guy
online cuz I don't follow him I don't
look at that stuff it was funny cuz I
didn't realize this dude was like a
YouTuber we're talking about this dude
keemstar I don't even know if he's even
a thing anymore I don't know who he is I
don't I've literally never even like
looked at his channel I don't he very he
could be the biggest thing online right
now the thing is this story takes place
before he was ever that guy back in
Buffalo I think I don't know when the
thing is I don't know if he was or not
yeah we're talking
like Ariana was like probably two or
three this over 10 years before you even
moved you lived in Buffalo New York yeah
this is a long ass time ago and it was
like what happened well it was a tricky
little situation cuz it was like this I
was a new dad me and April had an
apartment I was starting to like become
an adult and then I kind of got thrown
into the situation like my brother was
in jail you know like I kind of got
thrown into this situation where I felt
like I was going to have to Dera my
whole [__] life over this [__]
dude because he was roommates with
April's Aunt we went over this April's
aunt and April had been out stop sorry
this guy was roommate with April's a
yeah cuz his girl oh so April knows him
well
yeah I didn't know I'm sorry never once
did I ask that I didn't know this I
thought he was just some guy at a party
no so it was like his girl oh was
April's Aunt the one who I filmed her
wedding uh that's like her best friend
so that's how they live together
and this is way worse this was like it
was it was so stupid now understand why
you got what you were doing when you got
mad now I get it I thought it was a
random person at a party with Mar you're
insane no like her aunt lived in this
house like they lived
together I April and her aunt lived
together and then I moved in and then we
had a [__] kid so her aunt moved out
when she moved out she moved in with
them
oh so that Keem guy I had no idea who
the dude even was yeah you know who he
was yeah April used to go out with her
friends and [__] and she was out with
Mandy and you know like some situation
happened where he was talking [__] to
Mandy and that's a nogo for April so
then I guess April got in his face and
then you know he got [__] Slappy
hands and kind of like scratched her up
and [__] and it was a whole [__]
incident he pit her in the face and
scratched her neck up wasn't like which
is a weird thing to do to a girl yeah it
wasn't it wasn't like a they didn't like
fight but she had scratches and [__] on
her neck you know what I mean like it
was enough to the point that he got
arrested that night so like for doing
that yeah okay so I find out about this
maybe you know [__] 5 in the morning
I'm home with
Ariana oh so when April's telling me all
this he's R's already in jail like this
situation had already
unraveled and like I remember it was
like dark out super early in the morning
I called my boy
like cuz at that time I was so on the
secret I had literally like brainwashed
myself into like believing I could have
this amazing life and I was doing it and
like I was just so shocked that I was
like why am I being put in this position
right
now like I felt like I had no way no way
around like ruining my life over this
[__] so I called my boy and was like
[__] with your baby mom [__] with your
girl yeah no you could I mean like he
gave me the clear like I mean you got to
go ahead like basically like yeah no I
know I got the [__] like all this
crazy [__] was running through my mind
IM this a long time ago it's not this is
2010 you got to understand the other
thing like I'm even in that call I was
just like it was almost like like I was
questioning like God to him me and him
talked about that [__] all the time cuz
with a lot of my boys if I would even
[__] brought this up
like I used to hang out with some
[__] Killers like it was it would
have been it could have gotten really
[__] out of control but it really put
me in a little bit of a dark place for a
while because I didn't know who this
dude was but I mean I knew enough so
then I went on this and again we're
talking a long time ago but I then went
on this little mission of trying to set
this fo
up calling him pay phones trying to book
him cuz he was a
DJ I'm going down to Wilson Farms I'm
going over here I'm hitting his phone
like yo I'm trying to I'm having this
party I'm trying to lure him over to the
east side on a back
block that was my plan bro we're gonna
I'm gonna have him I'm GNA book him for
an event and like we're going to lure
him over here and it's a WAP like that
was the plan I was like I was he didn't
answer his phone I was I called his
proba [__] five times from pap fres
and
[__]
uh yeah so then
um yeah one night we went I I was like
sick of waiting on that [__] so we just
recruited my same boy that I was just
talking about who was older than me like
grew up in that Griselda
era uh you know and
like I already went over this [__] but
like yeah I went and picked him up and I
got he was he was Voting he went he was
voting for Obama the night this happened
I didn't
vote I was posted up in front of my
boy's house just smoking waiting for him
while they went and
voted and I got so high way higher than
I usually get mixed with my anger and
just mixed with like I don't want to be
in this [__] I used to get in stupid
[__] predicaments like this I don't
want to be in this [__] [__] you know
like but yeah I mean uh then this whole
situation unfolded where we went looking
for this dude
and [__] laying up on his house and
[__] and April's aunt was all in front
of the house on the phone not even
knowing we're
there and uh you to say it better when
we're off camera you say it more
detailed Marty was laying in the bushes
no it was like waiting for a full at his
house I was I I like was too high I
really was cuz I remember feeling like
like we spun around the corner I had
never even been over on the street I'm
pretty maybe like once to drop I I
didn't even know where I was really
going I had like a map or some [__] it
was in South Buffalo so like yeah we
spun around the corner and a bunch of
people saw us like just regular people
and then like I'm looking around for the
street and then I come back around the
corner again and then I come back around
again and then they saw us again and
then my boy's like oh we're hot right
now we're hot I was like [__] they did
you know like not that they're even
probably paying attention but you see me
and him around here yeah so then I pull
over and we hop out and then we're just
kind of like walking around on the
streets and then we go into this we like
go down by the house and the house is on
a dead end and I'm kind of looking at it
and it's just dark you know it's like
winter and so then we going into this
little bar at the top of the street and
like blatantly don't belong at all this
is like a the little area saw Buffalo is
known as like a racist like oh it's one
of it's this goofy little area where
it's like directly it like touches the
[__] east side but it's known for
being like a racist [__] like white
area but uh we went in this bar and my
boy picked up a bag of heroin on the
floor this little white baggies like oh
[__] somebody dropped this should I
remember that like oh damn it's like
that huh we're just sitting in this bar
just like this dude's going to walk in
like we're just passing time and
[__] and then we posted up and we sat in
front of the house for like a long ass
time
I had on gloves I had all my [__] he had
all this [__] like and April's aunt was
like pacing around the front of the
house on the [__]
phone and we ended up
leaving this was like the night before
two nights before
Halloween and
uh I had this whole other plan
afterwards that my boy wasn't with on
Halloween and after that I
like I was just feeling so dark at that
time I hated
it I really hated it
um because it's like I just didn't want
to be in that
position so then uh a little bit of time
went by not that much time but
like there was this
other situation where
like
uh his so his girl is still friends with
April's like everybody like the police
know about this [__] that's the other
thing like you went to jail he caught a
case over this [__] like people this
isn't this is some blatantly obvious
[__] if he comes up [__] something
wrong with him like I'm immediately the
first person every's going to be looking
at I already accepted that I was already
going to visit my brother in prison at
this time I was just starting my life
with April like this [__] was not didn't
feel good at all but like really
bothered me so then
I like planned on this trip to take
April to
Toronto uh and I had my Cadillac that I
just bought and it was basically a lemon
but I put this system in it and
like booked us a hotel up in Toronto and
went to we went to drive uh over the
Peace
Bridge to get to Toronto and they
stopped us at the border oh CU April and
they started questioning about some [__]
and then because April had a misdemeanor
they said we don't want you turn around
you can't come back for 10
years if you try to come back we'll
arrest you yeah yeah so we turn back
around and my caddy dies in the uh in
the toll booth in the in the Customs
they make us turn around and when I turn
around in the Customs Lane my [__] dies
and starts smoking and [__]
everywhere so now I lost on the hotel
room you know I lost on this weekend
with April and uh now my car is like
that I just put my system in is [__]
shot I don't know what's going on so
then we had to get towed back to the
house so now we get towed back to the
house in April's aunt was watching
Ariana there and she had her friend over
that was bro's girlfriend oh okay I
didn't know that this girl was going to
be there when I got there but when I saw
her
like I I got so [__]
enraged that I damn near started to
[__] tear up and I left cuz I felt
like I was about to I was about to fight
this
girl she was hanging out in my house
this dude's girlfriend she didn't know
what the hell was going on she didn't
going she has no clue what's going on
but I just remember how mad I got like
vicious in my veins like I would never
felt like that about a [__] girl
before this girl has no clue what's
[__] going on probably I mean she
should seems pretty obvious to me not
that much time had passed but they don't
it wasn't even maybe that big of a deal
I guess should be it was to me yeah
sounds like
it it sounds like
it you know but I don't know like what
ultimately ended up happening with his
coure case or whatever we ended up
moving here like shortly
thereafter uh uh I don't really know
anything about this dude other than that
I know
that he dodged God was with him you know
what I mean like and we're not saying
you're threatening people now over 10
years ago I just it keep I'm glad bro
wasn't around cuz I mean when I was
looking for him I'm glad bro wasn't
around yeah cuz it's like stupid [__]
like that like I mean who knows who the
[__]
knows you know maybe we're not sitting
here right now I don't know over over
[__] nothing yeah over nothing not
nothing but over something that could be
solved yeah and ultimately April could
probably see him in the hands anyway
that's what I my [__] thought was
like damn
like normally
she'd yeah [__] do it up yeah she I
don't know what the deal was you know I
don't I don't know why her hands were
lacking at night is basically what Marty
just said
I think moral of the story the end of
the story was he got one over on her I
guess now if I would have met her like
that it wouldn't have married her but
she got stabbed when I met her so that's
why I married her
yeah she was basically just
like like part of my life was like you
have to just [__] let this go yeah
it's not like again
again long time ago I just think it's
wild I see this guy and I brought him up
and you go when you I'm like who is he
and you said his name I go I've heard
that name yeah and looked him up I've
seen this guy this is the guy like the
guy on social media yeah I don't is the
guy you're talking I've never I couldn't
even tell you like where he's at I've
never even looked at his page I I don't
know what he does I don't know what he
does I just know he pops up on my
Twitter all the time he's like like like
like a social media I think he might be
a streamer uhhuh I don't know he's kind
of like he talks about news
I don't know I've seen him on other
streamers platforms April said he's
[__] huge I don't know we we chuckled
about how [__] huge this dude was
afterwards you know oh no I don't I
don't I don't have any clue I don't know
if he's still thing I feel like could
could be wrong but he pops up a lot when
I see like DJ academics type of stuff
mhm like news news in this news in that
this person but like only pops up on my
Twitter on random stuff that people text
so and so does this like like a like a
social media influencer news and he has
a big beard that's why I always remember
him he's got a big beard but I mean I
don't know the guy I'm not s sitting
here saying like yo we want to box you
no no no we're just talking about a
story and I think it's kind of funny
that like the guy on the podcast that's
super nice like that's the guy we're
talking about so Random he's the guy
that in his head there's so many shitty
scumbags walk around [__] capable of
domestic violence type of slapping a
girl type of [__] it's just was funny
this the [__] this guy he he reports
on drama stuff I think that's what he
talk about like news like uhhuh report
on that yeah report on that [__]
on on that dude that's crazy he got what
it called he got all Slappy hands with
April that's what you used to call you
got all Slappy hands with
her Dam you Slappy hands the girl and
scratched her wow anyway sorry we're not
sitting here like beef it's not if we
saw him walking down the street probably
be like yo that Armenian guy oh he looks
nice yeah like oh that's the that's the
guy that's him we wouldn't know him
because we don't that's not like our
lane of stuff we're not saying like oh
he's he's not big enough we don't know
we Pro April's like he's huge like damn
that's good for him two fools out of
Buffalo doing stuff that's great two two
you know what I mean connected somehow
mhm yeah man Mar looks so pissed off was
like you guys should have seen his face
when I talked to like but you got to
talk about the king
starting I just yeah we'll talk about it
you're so pissed no you got to
understand I'm the type of person that I
carry [__] with me for a long time
something really bothers me it it's kind
of with me on my mind for a long [__]
like years yeah I get it it'll just be
slightly annoying me for a long [__]
time you know oh for
sure you know [__] like that but it's
all [__]
good report on that I don't know I just
think it's funny there's a lot of stuff
oh man we could say so many things
there's a lot of stuff I mean it's not
like and that right there like if you
don't care about it why' you talk about
it cuz I wanted Marty to talk about it
because we've talked about this before
and every time I see the guy I go this
is the guy we're talking about so I just
thought it was funny all right because a
lot of you from season one know that
story and now you're like kind of weak
not to say his name season one like yeah
you didn't want to say his name you
didn't want to talk about who it was but
also we're not those type of people like
yeah and this guy let's talk about it
we're not into the whole podcast beef
thing
you know what I'm saying so there's just
a lot of stuff that we we didn't talk
about like today I'm about to get into
some I'm going get a long I'm a long
story right now but I think we should
light up Jo it's been 36 minutes yeah
YouTube you got to respect it God damn
30 minutes did that little story
jointless jointless you have yours right
there which one you suggest here what
you um I don't know I don't
know that one's from Sacramento it's we
don't smoke the same uh I right off the
bat I could tell they were from Northern
California they're all cool these ones
try that one try that
one and this one's called Bars by
Blaine all right let's do this what's up
everybody it is officially December
Christmas time is coming and for the
holiday seasons make sure your balls
aren't gross you're about to be around
your family and stuff so you need to
make sure so right now if you don't have
nasty dick and balls get it for a friend
and when you get it go to manscape.com
use our code to checkout Yola code Yola
is 20% off plus free shipping it doesn't
get any better if you have the guy in
your life you have your uncle or your
dad or something you don't know what to
get him just get him some manscape stuff
they're going to see it on there like oh
yeah it's for men they have the
performance package 5.0 just in time for
the holidays the weed whacker nose hair
trimmer you guys already know that comes
with the whole package comes with every
single thing you can think of they also
have subscriptions the peak hygiene plan
you can get on a monthly based
subscription they also have the beard
hedger Pro kit the beard oil the be they
have every single thing to make sure
you're on point this holiday season
remember that's code Yola at
manscape.com code Yol is 20% off plus
free shipping on anything and everything
so as always guys thank you to manscape
for supporting the show and thank you
for supporting the brands that support
us back to the episode all right here we
go
guys
remember when I say but I don't care
enough like I don't care it doesn't like
bother me the reason I'm about to talk
about what I'm talking about and like if
you don't care why' you talk about it
because I am bugged about it 80 times a
day every live chat every interview I
have ever done anywhere else people
bring this up or this person up and I
just like beat around it like oh yeah no
I never really met really that much
because I don't like talking about stuff
like I don't I don't care about the
drama I don't care about yeah so and so
this I don't care enough that's why I
don't talk about the [__] but at this
point like Marty how many times a day do
we get asked about this like
every day it just there's certain things
in the Cannabis community that it's like
why kind of weird huh I never thought
about that no they haven't it's just
kind of awkward so what I'm about to
talk about you guys are going to be very
like whoa really this is something it's
not it's nothing it's not a thing it's
it's a it's a
mutual I'm good that's how I think me
and this other guy feel about each other
and the reason for it I think is
miscommunication because I don't care
enough to hate on
someone how many times we brought him up
we go f don't like me and then I just
keep talking yeah it's kind of don't
like me and I just keep doing what I was
doing and like everybody goes why like
and I mean everybody when my personal
Friends Ask me about this person go
honestly man I think he just don't like
me I'm I'm good either way bro you know
like I don't I don't care like I got
[__] to do I have a i we have a great F
fans I got I it's not like I need some
you know what I mean but you want to
make [__] happen for the fans when you
know they want that's why we're even
talking about this thing because it's
every single day every day I get tagged
50 times every time I've done an
interview how come you don't have so-
and so on the show oh just we just
haven't connected yet man that's my com
like that's what I say to everyone we
just haven't connected yet I'm sure we
will we just haven't connected yet I say
that everywhere I go because we're both
in the Cannabis space so what I'm about
to get into guys remember this is not
a oh hater oh I don't like that this is
not what this is I don't want people
going to people's pages and hating on
[__] this is to clear the air all right
this is 100% just to clear the air
because we get asked so much and at this
point it's almost awkward that we aren't
talking about it because people ask so
much and I've seen other comments of
other people and they're sitting there
thread long thread talking about yeah it
is kind of weird something must be wrong
they must not like you something must
have happen nothing happened and here
we're going to go and I like remember
people are going to say if you don't
care why you talking about it it's
because the fans need to know why I feel
this way because I explain myself very
very very very well I go into long
detail about everything cuz I don't want
you to Mis hear me I don't want anything
to be messed up I don't want want my
information to be skewed in any way
shape or form so I'm going to talk about
this and this is exactly what's been
going on and let me throw it back to
when I was like 17 years old so guys who
I'm talking about what I'm talking about
is a lot of you have asked for this
person to be on the show but a lot of
you have asked this question how come
you never do anything with cookies how
come you never ever ever have done an
interview with Burner how come you guys
don't do cookies reviews I've never
never seen cookies in any of your videos
Thomas you never even been to the store
you know what now that I think about it
do these fols not like each other I get
that all the time in my DM and guys I've
got that for the past seven years so
it's not like oh he's just trying to get
content huh oh he's going to talk about
it because a couple people asked seven
years straight since DMS came to
Instagram it's been happening since we
started a podcast I have right here how
many times we get oh my
God it's constant when you're going to
have burer on the show when you're going
to have burner on the show and what I
always say is I'm sure we will I'm sure
we will I'm sure we'll connect I'm sure
we will because I don't want to talk
about what the awkward situation is and
I know obviously you're going to see
this too so the so B obviously I got no
ill feelings I am getting high at my
house I'm smoking balls and taking
dabs don't care but I need to say it
because I need to say what I say to my
friends because I there's something's
missing there is a line of communication
that is crossed because when I talk we
have I have a friend that knows him a
couple friends that know him and a
couple of his friends know me sure and
they've brought it up before by you guys
don't do nothing but I gotta be honest
man I just don't know if he I don't know
if he likes me that much it's I got
awkward Vib like I always wonder why you
guys never did nothing together cuz you
guys are both in the weed space
California Dow you guys are you guys are
like opposites different different but
the same like we do a lot of similar
things I just you know I'm like more
just like making people laugh He makes
music even his own homies have been like
nah cuz you both like smoking weed and
watching funny stuff you guys will get
along so what's the problem I go bro I
don't know and I always end it with this
got to be honest though like I don't
care enough to like let it to make me
wonder like I did for the first couple
months I was like what did I did I do
something did I do something so let's
start it off so 100% ah we got no ill
feelings whatsoever do your thing how
many times Rosie have I go that fool
don't like me crushing it though oh yeah
yeah he's crushing it damn he's crushing
that's sick we both talk about we talk
about like that I don't know I mean I
don't care that's just like I don't care
like I don't you know when it's like oh
that F don't like me so you don't like
dislike the person you just go do your
thing I don't I mean I
don't not in my realm not in my mind
indifferent yeah just indifferent like I
don't good for you though bro like I saw
you know how many people tagged me in
the Forbes cover I went damn Brown fo in
the cover of Forbes oh [__] that's sick
like even I'm juice and I kept scrolling
I was like ah we probably be homies but
I don't care enough to go reach out and
be like yo we should hang out if we bump
into each other we hit it off we hit it
off I feel like burner and I are Step
Brothers Dale and Brennan and I think
there's
a are we are we do we have similar
interest but yeah bro we probably do cuz
all his homies like what you guys smoke
weed and like laugh at stuff why
wouldn't it be a friendship go I don't
know about just doing my thing that's
how it's happened from a lot of our like
we have like two three Mutual like rap
homies yeah and uh you guys guys have
put like entrepreneurship through like
weed branding like in social media the
thing is like we don't follow each other
our guarantee not searching my page
doing his own thing just like I'm doing
my own thing so when people tag me on
stuff is the only time I see stuff from
him so like oh damn good [__] and I just
go back to my life because I
don't we're in it's an indifferent so
this is me clearing the air I want to
talk about it because we're going into
2024 all right we're going to 2024 I I'm
fully trying to we're we're about to do
a lot of good stuff a lot of great
things and this is for the fans I'm
talking about this you guys know there's
a lot of people that I I'm not going to
do stuff with I don't work with just we
we don't see eye to eye but I'm not
sitting here going no I don't like that
this is I'm only talking about this
cookies burner thing because people ask
they want it so bad you guys ask so bad
and this is the reason why on the chat I
always go yeah maybe one day yeah we'll
see yeah we'll get we we'll we'll get
back to you I always say that cuz I
don't know where it stands and I'm not
going to be like booking manager reach
out to his booking manager so we could
talk bro if we talk we talk if we don't
we don't but this is our invitation to
you like if you want to there's a seat
right there come down cuz our fans have
been asking constantly and I think it'd
be good I think it'd be good to like
hey that's that's not my number that
that number texts you you suck that's
not even my number and then we go wait
what I think that's what it is cuz
honestly man I don't
care so let's get let's get into it to
show you like I I really like I really
don't care like I didn't have any ill
feeling so let's get into this story
because I go into detail a lot here we
go 17 years old
18 so fresh is a store in Santa Cruz the
Catalyst has a lot of Bay Area artists
at Santa Cruz venue right by uh street
light records
Sam I mean Sam um damn Santa Cruz
there's a store like I said so fresh
Matt and Jack Own It Jack is DJ Fresh I
mean sorry Jack is DJ rxs they always
have a lot of DJ that's where I found DJ
Fresh albums DJ Fresh presents that's
where I found the dowlo album that's
where I found um roach gigs they gave me
the first roach gigs roachie bboa so I
was going in there buying a lot of
hip-hop albums a lot of Records I'm a
burner fan very big burner fan I was
trapping it out he's talking about
trapping it out Jacko was one of my
favorite rappers ever and then drought
season came out drought season 1 is one
of the best collaboration albums of all
time I still bump it and every time I
hear it I'm like God I wonder why this F
don't like me I swear and I'm like I
don't care I still bump it I'm like go
that first album all the verses on that
album are too hard I I think about them
all the
time you know what I mean like I'm I'm a
burner fan I have the first six of his
albums autographed by him oh [__] all my
burner albums are
autographed all of them I have burner
autographed posters like you met them
and you signed them or you bought like
seven times I've met this guy oh [__]
okay so back to this so fresh they would
do in stores right before the guys go on
the stage they do in stor sign records
sell merch out of so fresh it's a hipop
store this just made me sad [__] oh you
didn't know that I'm sorry see see we're
not sitting here just talking [__] about
you man like even Mario doesn't know
about some of this stuff cuz we don't
talk we don't it is what it is bro if
it's going to happen it's going to
happen you're going to be nice you're
going to be like friends with us if
you're not totally cool keep smoking
your weed doesn't suck because you're
not friends with me and my weed doesn't
suck cuz I'm not friends with you do
your thing my kids got a cookies hoodie
see what I'm saying all right look all
right here we go so
um they used to let me you know cut the
line at the in stores cuz I was
shireen's little brother
and Ralph was the manager of street
light records so Ralph knows mad and
Jack they like those the stream little
brother like oh you like hip hop she
like actually I have his album you can
sign like skip the come over here theyed
to skip the line I met Jacka and Hustler
when he first got out of prison all that
stuff I met everybody there dude so I
meet burner there and I buy the first
cookie shirt before there's it's a
cookies brand it's so fresh times
cookies and it's the Girl Scout cookie
face the green but she's blowing smoke
yeah I I hope he watches this I have
that first shirt damn that was one of
the first people to get it the day you
dropped it in Santa Cruz I was an 18
years old didn't even have my weed just
got my weed card so they they gave me a
large Sam uh Matt he's like I I saved
you
one bro you got me the the burn Shir oh
my God is this all pre- tayor gang like
he was on his pre- tayor gang okay yeah
it's pre- Instagram I'm selling packs
only it's all I'm doing selling packs
working at me and Edge going to college
burner
fan it's going to make you guys like I'm
a fan of people when I'm a look at look
look you're really a fan of people I'm a
fan of people if if I like your M and I
liked it I'm not going to be like oh he
don't like me we we don't [__] with each
other but that first album
man like I'll still love it and like
like listen to what I'm about to say to
you
I was 18 years old I got the shirt I
didn't even take a picture cuz I only
had a flip phone because I was trapping
and I didn't have a smartphone because I
didn't want P I didn't care about
pictures I didn't even get a picture
with bur I didn't get a picture of Jack
I got a picture with none of these it's
got autographs like all my posters
signed in my house that's it wasn't even
the picture era yet no hell no I had a
koi koi y so by the way this is burning
BL Bars by blame this is burning fire
so here we go I get my cookie shirt
before it's even cookies I'm like oh my
God hell yeah and then we go to the show
at Catalyst and they let me in the 21
and up section I'm 18 I'm upstairs I
meet Jay Stalin I'm a Jay Stalin fan I
meet him like oh my god did I just meet
Jay I'm 18 years old like dude I love
this [__] got his album like he said
what up he's so nice hell
yeah so I'm I'm uh still standing there
and Jack or Matt's like yo you want to
meet burner I go what so you want you
want to meet him and I
went Matt you know I want to meet him
and it was me and Jus are you ready for
what I'm about to tell you the story I'm
about to tell
you this is why I go above and beyond
like all the time so like when I meet
people on the first and like they like
make my day listen to this people think
man I hope you're listening to this [__]
you think I'm hating on you and I don't
like you listen to the story I'm about
to tell listen to this it's me and Jus
18 years old in the 18 and up section
like
this we're not even I mean the 21 and up
section like how the hell we're the
Catalyst we go to Catalyst all the time
nicotina shows everything we always look
up to the 21 and up section we can never
go up there now I'm looking down going
I'm not even allowed to be here hell
yeah so there we are we way up there for
like five minutes Matt comes back MADD
comes back back with Burner I'm like oh
[__] I'm like yo big fan man thank you
and I'm wearing the shirt he's like hey
the shirt go thank you appreciate it Jus
meets him like yo we appreciate he goes
bro thank you for listening and he goes
actually stay right here give me one
second fol goes back downstairs goes to
the Green Room where I would be five
years later chilling with B real and
methan and smoking right behind that
door like 5 years later right behind
that door we'd be smoking it out cuz
we'd be doing the weed influence stuff
anyway making videos like I always
wonder what was behind that door and now
I know anyway that's that's that's later
goes through that door comes back out he
goes here man smoke that and this fo
gives me a nug like a two gam nug and he
goes That's the Cherry Pie and went the
Cherry Pie he had just dropped a song we
talked about the cherry pie in it this
is like 2009 or 10 I remember when I put
Weekend at Bernie's the album into my CD
player as I was taking a delivery the
first delivery of the day on a Saturday
when I was working at me and EDS and I
was all 210 [__] and I went damn it's
2010 wonder what I'm going to be doing
in like 10 years and I put the album on
I just started driving smoking bows
taking my deliveries and then you know
what I mean then a month later he gave
me a nug of cherry pie I'm like what wow
whoa and I listen and he's like yeah
keep smoked that went thank you man
appreciate it no picture no nothing he
left the second guy I you me and G was
like lost our mind like yo what didn't
smoke the nug went back to Ralph's house
cuz that's where we stayed Ralph went
back to Ralph's house took it out of my
pocket and me and Jus for like 20
minutes talked about how could we
preserve it and put it in a
frame like yo you know who just gave us
this nug we can't smoke it we got to
save it bro what like that's how Juiced
I was so to say for people to be and
then it anyway we'll get we'll go on to
that
later bro it was a two G nug I was
willing to to FR epoxy and frame it I'm
a fan okay I'm a fan fast forward but
hold on what who ended up smoking the
nug me smoked it that night cuz it
started it start what happened was in my
pocket through the concert and it got
kind of compacted to where the tricomes
kind of get like pushed down and it kind
of look like a flat nug instead of like
the Tricom down I mean when he handed to
me I could not believe I was like this
fo just gave me a
n my is you every day The Jacka every
day I so bad what a cool move yeah
exactly that's why I do that [__] to
people all the time I do it all the time
everywhere I go I give people [__] yeah
like yo have a have a good day man for
real planted that seene in your mind
that and uh equipto being really nice to
me like a year before that he's a rapper
he was super nice to me and Christopher
Titus when he was real nice to me I was
if I ever get like fans I'm going to
very nice to him MH because why not
anyway um fast forward a couple years
I'm just trapping out doing my thing
drought season 2 comes out D season
three comes out traffic comes out with
uino uh the messy Mar or no traffic was
with uino in The
Jacka no that's Devil's Rejects it was
traffic yeah it was traffic I'm slipping
it's been a while anyway uh I started
Instagram let's move on to the story
guys I'm telling you all these pieces
because I want you to see fan fan fan
fan still a fan still a fan and where it
started
going I feel weird like super supporting
someone I feel like is kind of like
doesn't like
me
yeah you know like
yeah which is not like I'm not trying to
be a hater like well if you like the
stuff before no it's not I like the
stuff before listening to the words of
someone that I'm like oh that guy's kind
I don't know if he he's kind of I don't
know if he's mean to me is he not like
me or it's hard to listen to somebody
you can't you're like connecting with
somebody when yeah you're connecting
with somebody that I personally like I
don't think he likes me though like I
didn't do nothing though that's why I
felt like I never did nothing what made
you think that here we go so guys here
we
go I start Instagram I start making my
nug toy pictures start doing all that
one day I'm like what about backgrounds
to my pictures instead of just cool
scene my couch in the background I was
like What if I started putting
CDs I CD connoisseur over here and I'm
like what about like a trap Lord nug I
had a miniature desk a miniature gun
revolver a miniature phone bags little
plants a nug I
put a google eyes on
him got real close it looked like a
whole scene some dude like almost like
Scarface when he's like
this on in the bathtub yeah it was like
that look but he had a desk full of
other I had Jarred up weed in miniature
jars like a trap house and in the back I
put the White Album burner's White Album
with the chick on the cover to Tom
signed autograph I have all this is
autograph in in in uh uh silver paint
marker because it was a white Apple so
it had a pop on it
sick oh yeah fool bur I'm the kid you
kept trying to buy all the Niner hats up
off
of you
remember I have all those vintage Niner
hats I wore at every one of his shows
and he was always whenever you want to
sell those hats I'm like I can't sell
them bro my grandpa's my grandp just
passed away too I'm like I can't sell it
to you he he remembered and recognized I
mean he asked me to do two different
times anyway damn what happened to those
hats have them all oh [__] have all of
them have all of them man I gave Three
Hats to three Niner fans of my homies
because they're vintage like 8
I'm like yo you'll take care of it
you'll take care of it you'll take care
of it it's okay I have 35
more keep it
anyway I make the pictures with you know
the wi album I make like 12 pictures
with Burner
CDs as the backdrops wow but like viral
pictures dude I'll find them and we're
going to put them up in this in this
episode out of focus can you see that
that's what they are yes yeah you can
see that's what they are the caption to
her his lyrics of the album gotcha like
I'm just I'm just a fan man I'm just a
fan this is like me and Benny basically
yes I'm just a fan I'm just a fan I'm
traing it out I was selling packs this F
was doing nothing 10 10 racks two moves
that's a good look like that's all I was
trying to do too like I'm the lyrics I'm
bumping in my head daily like oh God
come on man like that was my [__] and
Jack that was my stuff anyway I'm making
all these pictures I start gaining like
a real big following everything's going
good
and then I'm not look it the reason I'm
saying this is because I only talking
about my point of view his point of view
might be I don't remember that and
that's fine or that's not what I went
that's not what I was saying to you and
that's not what the vibe I was trying to
give you Thomas my bad or maybe it was I
don't know but this is I'm saying sorry
I'm saying it in this story because I
need you guys to know where I'm at Super
Fan why I felt that way I did why why I
acted
or continued to feel the way I did and
remember this is not a exposing burner
thing at all this is just how I feel
from a Fan's perspective his perspective
might be I don't know this
fool but the reason I'm bringing this up
because like two years ago I found out
that he does know this fool and that's
why we're talking about this cuz
remember for eight years all I thought
was he probably doesn't even know who I
am maybe he just doesn't care I don't
care who I am that's not what I mean
like he probably doesn't know that I'm a
fan he probably thinks I'm just hating
on him I've never done cookie stuff uh
blah blah blah BL blah but I will figure
out I'll find I'll tell you soon but we
have one person that we both know and
I'm not friends with this person no more
right after that is when all of this
hating stuff started to happen okay and
I'm not trying to blame it on that but I
know
exactly why how this person talks I know
the thing things that he said about
other people that I'm like bro that's
not true I know that fool I can only
imagine what he said about me mhm to
burn yeah oh I gotta do you see what I'm
saying yeah totally so here we go make
all these pictures all this stuff
great I'm the raw
Ambassador I see
bur at the High Times cup I'm like yo uh
I talk to Josh you want me to get a
picture with you he goes oh yeah for
sure man I take a picture with him like
yeah nice to meet you man totally cool
nothing wrong fine I'm like oh okay cool
this is at the time I made a bunch of
pictures for him I just didn't want to
Fan out on him I didn't feel weird I had
just made all those pictures with Burner
back I just want hey man my name's
Thomas you know I'm a raw representative
Josh asked me to get a picture with you
could I get a picture he go yeah for
sure we took the picture I'll find that
picture too and I'm just like
that taking a picture with him you know
with all the other ra people yeah that
was it like
nothing I just need I want to get the
picture because we're raw he did raw at
the time he was the other raw person
this way before he started his other
company um so like that's it couple
years go by nothing
like it's not like oh he didn't follow
or like your picture so you thought he
didn't like you no I'm still just here
fine I'm I'm chilling like yeah burner
is burn like I'm still making my
pictures I'm getting my following push
trees is started
no weird feelings of any kind are here
yet and this is where I started feeling
like did I do something wrong because up
to this point I'm just a fan remember
that I'm just a fan that has a big
following in the Wii Community I'm a fan
of this guy buying his albums
consistently
like nothing wrong so here we go for a
lot of you don't know this I used to run
all the cookies
pages I didn't even know
that for real yeah I could have swore I
told you
that no doesn't really ring a bell I
knew raw P I started running the raw
page I did a story time called the truth
about raw papers you want to hear that
story go watch it all I used to run the
raw Rolling Papers
page I sparked that page to blow up I
gave him the steps and we talked about
that I didn't realize you're supposed to
be getting paid for some of that stuff
but it's okay you know it is what it is
I learned my lesson now I mark it for
myself um I started running all the
cookies Pages everything cookies uh SF
cookies
Sacramento and then there was one other
one that was like a cookies like
adjacent it wasn't cookies yet so what
happens is kind stack kind stack is like
a a medtainer not a medtainer kind stack
is like
like
two three like hockey puck things that
you put your weed in right cookies
released one of those but they they did
their own they used to do one with
somebody called uh kind stag I went to
meet with that guy he was super nice and
I'm like oh you do the cookie stuff
remember I'm just like a weed person
like oh yeah you do the cookies one he
goes no we don't do it with them no more
I'm like oh okay the only reason I
brought it up is because that's why I
knew of them too was like long story
short some San Francisco [__] I go meet
up with mint worldwide their clothing
company and uh remember guys I had never
made a legal Dollar in my
life to run all the four cook three
cookies Pages they paid me four bands a
month
Marty were you having to so you're like
making I would drive to San Francisco
and Sacramento once a month pick up one
of every single thing they have in the
store so I can film it shoot it and run
the Instagram oh [__] so I was getting
thousands of dollars of weed thousands
of dollars of weed each store
then they pay me four bands I was
struggling to make my rent and he goes
how about 4K I
went in my head I'm like I'm would have
[__] throw remember when we got back
in the car yeah lost my mind could not
believe that could not believe that I I
could make my rent finally cuz I was
just struggling just started push trees
like I was just struggling and like yeah
we'll pay you $500 per page a week and
in my head I went it's four for four
band a month I'm like yeah that's fine
cool so I can just see him like yeah I'm
used to this yeah Luke I you could have
paid me 2K you could have paid me 2K
Luke I would did it for two sorry um
so I read the page for a couple months I
go meet worldwide I didn't know you're
not supposed to tell people money stuff
he asked me's like how much do they pay
you and I'm just like oh you're nice you
you give me clothes I'm just going to
tell you how much I get paid yeah cuz
you asked versus how would you answer
that now I'm like y you know they pay me
man like I it varies yeah because that
makes people feel weird I didn't know
that it's not other people's business I
didn't know I didn't know that they were
just he was just asking to ask I'm only
saying this because I was fired two days
later right mint were W and cookies are
very close I'm I'm only going to say I'm
only saying this because I thought it
was kind of odd I'm like I got fired two
days after I've told somebody how much I
got
what and remember this is speculation
if I'm burner watching this going that's
not
true bro I don't know I'm only talking
about the things that I see you're POV
remember this is all I told M more W how
much you get paid he goes four bands and
I
go I'm happy is that good yeah I was
like he's like that's a lot I go I got
him 50k in one month on two pages 50k
52k and 48k on one page I know what I'm
doing I got raw 250,000 29 days 20 one
days come on man I know what I'm doing
like there's a reason why I'm doing this
there a reason you gave me the reins to
go
anyway do that right this is where I
started I only gave you that as
backstory because I I
think maybe here we go I go to San
Francisco I walk in dude I walk in and
literally the whole Line's like what yo
like in my I'm like people care this is
before I like gotten recognized
everywhere M like what okay so weed
stores everyone's going to be stoked
okay that's cool I didn't know that I
walked in I'm
like people are hyped oh man this is
cool anyway I go in the back office I'm
talking to Luke and it's where he gives
me a stack of money and weed he's like
hold on one second we're just talking
we're just talking cuz Luke's a
hilarious ass person Luke and cookie
split so Luke is the owner connected the
big huge brand connected that's who I'm
talking talking about he split and did
his own thing so they used to be cookies
and then I don't know what happened they
had a falling out so now he's connected
yeah so this is pre falling out this is
when everybody was just cooking sorry
I'm only talking about this stuff guys
because you ask so much and you need to
know why I think the way I think and why
later on when I show you these tweets
when why I was
offended here we
go backstory King backstory King for
sure 28 minutes of backstory I don't
give a
[__] and there's going to be a bunch of
people like yeah he don't care he did a
35-minute story are you new I took a
[__] one time fell on my ass and my mom
found me I will tell that 90 minute
story like that'll take me 90 minutes to
talk about cuz I need to tell you what
was it you know who killer was see he
used to smoke crack and they made him
fight his that's how I feel like you
smoke entirely too much weed that's how
I feel see another thing when I saw the
cookies Half Baked thing I went damn
that's tight well I don't know about
about that people tag me on everything
so I'm not a hater bro I'm not a hater
if you do good [__] you do good [__] I
just don't care about the realm because
I feel like we have a weird a weirdness
so I'm like let me just watch that and
I'm going to go do my thing cuz I don't
care I'm going to do my own thing so
that's why uh we've never done anything
that's why he's not been on the show
because there's a weirdness and I'm I'm
getting into that we got we we we got
into a long confrontation and that's why
this is here
ready
I go I'm at the back of the cookie store
he pays me he goes hold I'm going take
this call he goes oh right now okay Luke
looks at me and goes could you film
something for me I go of course I'm your
social media guy what do you need he
goes burner Harry Gordy and B real are
about to be here and in my head I go did
you just say bur about to be here and be
real I just went to the 420 show with my
mom to go watch Cypress Hill three years
ago and now B's been he's sat here high
as hell wearing push trees on stage and
[__] come on man shout out to B real
um yeah I'm a fan man so he says that
and my and person I go yeah I could film
it in my head and go shut the [__] up oh
my
God holy [__] I'm like yeah let me know
what's up so he bust his phone out I
bust my phone out they walk in and it's
just some curly hair guy which is Harry
Gordy burn than some big giant buff ass
fool remember there's no DMS at the time
so it's all comments I talk to a lot of
Growers talk to a lot of people have
friendships online people I've never met
they walk
in and this is where I felt weird this
is why I was
like was that weird or is that my did I
do
something I go what's up man I go to
shake Harry Gord hand I shake his hand
and then I go to shake burner's hand and
then he just like turns around and hops
on the call and I was like
okay I'll I'll I'll introduce myself
after like weird timing or was he like I
don't like this guy mhm but I also don't
want to cause a scene because this is
weird I don't know then again like he's
probably at home going bro I don't even
remember that exactly that's why I'm
only telling my POV cuz I don't know
what you were thinking I just thought it
was weird I was like
oh I didn't mean to interrupt your am I
interrupting that's the worst I felt
awkward like am I
interrupting yeah I I'll introduce
myself to him after that's I was like
I'll I'll wait to you guys on the phone
I'll say hi I'm Thomas nice to meet you
bro I'm a big fan like I like what am I
way by the way I'm the fool from Santa
Cruz like I'm that dude Jack and Matt
you oh you know what I mean like I was
just waiting for that opportunity to go
bro Jack and Mt from Santa Cruz like I'm
the kid I'm the guy from I'm the little
guy I was a little kid
anyway and I was like oh that's cool and
I go to shake the next guy's hand big
buff ass fool and I go hey nice to meet
you man he he looks at me he's
like nice to meet
you and he goes I'm a Big Ass Fan dude
and just
goes no way and he's like all hyped up
he's like bro I'm such a fan I go yo
thank you he's like yelling in the
office is this like security dude or big
Mexican and he goes pulls me in close
I'm like damn and he goes
I'm Mr shabinsky and I'm like what he
goes I'm shabinsky me and him been
talking in comments for three
years like he's posting he's the Sher
guy like yo sick ass picture like Yo bro
we got to smoke one day like we just
talk because there's no DMS he goes I'm
shinsky Mario nice to meet you I'm like
what like Mr sh he's like Thomas yes the
one in the comments like bro and I get
all stoked and he's like oh my God he
goes would you smoke a joint with me and
I'm like Mr shabinsky is a fan like that
I am so happy is he like a legend in the
community yes Mr shabinsky shabinsky the
brand shinsky is the same person Mario
shout out to Mario shelato sherb this is
him
so here we go he's fan and I mean like I
was genuinely happy I'm like this is so
happy I am so is this still pre youube
i' had never done YouTube yet okay yeah
so actually this is about a month or two
right before no it's before my first
video the wake and bake video it's right
before my first video or maybe during
that long ago so I'm like yeah of course
man blah blah blah blah blah hell yeah
dude and he's like I'm going go to my
car all right and he runs out in my I'm
like yo Mr shiny is so happy to meet me
I am so Juiced this man is a legendary
breeder
grower I love making Instagram videos I
was like this I can't believe we are
here this bu's about to pay me four pant
I'm Gonna
Leave This lasted two months this job by
the way I got paid twice for the cookies
page yeah yeah the cookie stuff I got
paid twice but I mean 8K to do what I
was already going to do for you for free
yeah that was cool anyway he comes back
in with the weed and Luke looks at me
and goes hey we're going to do some
money stuff could you just step real
quick and then we'll film after I go
yeah of course so I walk out of the
office and stand right on the outside of
the door of the
office and then there's just fans in
line like yo and I'm like what's up I
take a picture with him like in line and
I'm just standing there and this is why
I felt weird all right here we go B I
don't know you so I don't know what to
what to call hey Method Man yeah you
know what I mean it's a deck I feel
weird every time I say the name I feel
like
hey like it feels weird like so cuz I'm
talking directly cuz people are OB going
to tag him 9 million times in this and
make it look like I'm being a dick and
talking [__] I'm only just talking about
what happened I'm standing there by the
door and I hear the door open I turn
around like oh you want me to film and
it's and it's burn he goes hey can you
give me some Waters and I
go and I head I don't know where to no
he goes you give some H20 and I'm
like I don't I don't I don't even know I
don't work here man I don't know where
they're at he goes oh my bad and he
looks at somebody else yo can you give
me some h2os and he like Clos the door
and
went
weird you know I don't work here like
that's all I felt like you know I don't
work here but also like maybe he doesn't
and that's me going and think
overthinking
going but you know I don't I've met you
like twice already I was just going to
introduce him he thas man with raw
remember we met you met you a couple
times actually I'm the guy from Santa
Cruz with MADD oh are you that's why I
was say I'm the dude with the Niner hat
you try to buy like bro for real you
still got those Niner hats that's what I
was going to hoping ready to Triple down
on I'm little kid the one you gave the
cherry and Pie to like damn fool for
real that's you I just it just never got
to come that's why I want to talk but he
got on he was on the phone I was like
yeah yeah oh oh wait oh wait yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying when you're a
fan of someone yeah you're like
oh by the way also I know your dad or
something you know what I mean like also
by the way yeah something like that
there's layers to yeah but in my head
I'm standing there the door closes I'm
like you know I don't work here right we
just I was
just maybe he thinks I work here like
I'm a social guy and I work here or
something all right all right but we've
met but it's okay I it's okay that's
where I was like huh
weird
Okay so let's move on that's that's
that's just and I'm look at remember
Guys these are just instances that I'm
breaking down going that was awkward
that was weird
H very odd and then uh cool right fast
forward a couple years I now meet the
person that we both know I meet this
person me and this person I'm not going
to put everything out there because that
is not my business to talk about what
they used to talk about okay that's not
my business but I have a certain friend
I have a certain friend that knows
burner and that guy knows me too very
well he knows him very well so obviously
when I show you some tweets later you're
going to that's who's the person he's
referring to the person he's referring
to played me very hard and I like I said
I love that fool but can't if I can't
trust you I can't be around you but uh
he's very close friends with this with
Burner so I'm
assuming when me and him had a falling
out he probably told this fool that I I
badmouth him or I do stuff or I I don't
know it's got to be something it has to
be something you don't just look at like
oh that guy doola stuff oh the guy yeah
I've never interacted with him but he
must hate on me yeah he hates on me
there's no way people just say stuff out
of nowhere there has to be some context
it has to be someone said
something because it doesn't make
sense I was just a fan so like talking
[__] like about what fo I like your
[__] what what was on SFI you like Asian
women isn't that racist if I like their
race how could that be racist sorry I
have the signf sure I had to do it um
yeah I'm I'm just I'm a fan I'm a fan I
paid a lot of money for the merch and
CDs and concerts I have autographed
posters
and what that's insane that'd be like
Benny getting here like yo Thomas I like
you you that you already made it right
you're the you're the fool talking [__]
you used to live in you still you been
hating on me since way back then like
what are you joking are you joking
that's how I feel in the situation like
what it has to are you joking it has to
be that it has to be that the 100% of
course it is bro of course it is that
fool anyway this Mutual person I don't
want to talk about him too much let's
just
say I've seen him say stuff about people
I'm like that's not true that's what I
mentioned earlier like I've seen I know
that guy that's not even true why are
you saying that about him are you making
[__] instigator oh man oh yeah exactly
mhm instigating person bro and me and
him are like this don't like each other
right now at that point and that's when
all of this started I noticed after me
and him stopped being friends so what
I'm going to talk about is
this nothing ever happened you know time
goes on life goes on we do this he's
doing his thing I'm doing my thing I
don't care if it doesn't concern me it's
not positive in my life I do not care
don't pay attention unless someone tags
me on it I I'm not you know how small
the square is on the tag you every time
someone tags you on something Marty it's
like I didn't post that what is that and
you click and go oh you're tagging me on
something yeah yeah that's that's when I
get updates like oh
oh weird cuz people tag me so much okay
so here we thanks for everybody that
tags us when these big companies put out
who's your favorite weed crators or
whatever yeah cuz that that's just
helped us out a little
bit um so continue ready this is where
everything
changes me and that guy don't like each
other anymore after that I feel like
nothing changed because we don't follow
each other we don't do videos with each
other I don't do cookies reviews I just
let it be you know like it's not in my
world it's not he's not in my world not
in his why would we not everybody has to
be best friends friends just move on and
there's like a slight awkwardness
because I felt that there was a slight
awkwardness even though I don't I've
only seen in person like what's up I
even felt like did I do
something I told you that in the
beginning this did I do
something mhm and I'm skaing in my head
like Thomas were you hating on this fool
and you just don't remember like first
off I don't remember something yeah
right full um like no because I've
talked to like say for instance JM Jilla
he brought it up like yo you should do
like a push trees cookies I'm like I
this is back when he was still working
for pink dolphin he knows burner well I
know J Jilla he knows J Jilla
well and he's like yo and I'm I told him
like I don't know if he likes me I got
to be honest bro this after me and my
homie fell out with each other like I
he's like really CU he he you guys would
get along you was watch good stuff and
like watch funny [__] and smoke
weed and do business like you guys
probably get along and go honestly man
I'm I was a fan I haven't bought an
album like two years cuz I don't it's
kind of awkward when I think the guys
kind of like don't like me and he even
said he goes something happened because
there's no reason for it like you guys
are not you're from the same state you
do the same [__] I go jerem believe me
when I tell you I I think I've thought
about it many times like what is the
problem I don't know the problem don't
care
at this point don't care doing my own
thing not everybody has to be homies I'm
it's fine but if like it was a case of
like yeah be homies like that yeah
what's up fool like of
course I waited in lines and [__] to
watch you so continue continue continue
anyway I got a fan base I'm doing my own
thing people you know what I mean like
I'm doing my stuff oh it's
drips so
continue fast forward it's 2021 we'll
put these up over the
screen and then this happened on Twitter
and uh the reason I'm bringing it up
once again people like damn you're
bringing up two-year-old tweets fool
what are you just trying to
like every day I get tagged on stuff all
right so when we started a podcast you
brought up mner 90 times the first time
you brought it up I said what that fo
hates
me that's all I ever say that fo after I
saw these tweets I went oh afle hates
I've never really fully understood this
this is this is this what's going on
like our mutual friend that has to be it
cuz here's the
tweets I've never said anything in
public about a
bad and the only time we've ever said
anything about the guy is when people
bring it up personally like boot Lake
Kev off camera he goes during our
podcast he brought up burner I was like
yeah man I saw that just
dope after he goes yo you should you
should you should you know you should
have him on you should have him on I go
yeah we just haven't connected goes I'm
surprised you guys never met go we've
met but like we don't we haven't done no
content we just never connect I'm sure
we will that's why I said to bootle C
then he came to our show and then he
asked about burner again and I told him
like that fool hates me and he went stop
what did you say I'm like you don't like
me I I said it funny I don't be like he
hates me Bo like and I went he don't
like me bro he goes why he goes I don't
know but it finally figured out like on
Twitter like yeah he don't like me so
before all this when people bring it up
and go oh we just haven't connected oh
maybe we will oh we just won't do this I
just said ah I don't care something's
off something he don't something's off I
only had speculation until I saw these
tweets all right so I'm about to talk
about this and this is why I want to say
it so burner right here when you tweeted
this is when I got my reassurance like
oh yeah yeah yeah there is awkwardness
something's off someone said something
because this don't make no sense cuz I'm
scanning my brain on people that know
you and I know you I only know P guy
which is your breeder Kenny PW shout out
to Cy P I saw him two nights ago I told
Rosie saw Kenny Powers he walked up to
me at an event I'm what's up F he goes
how you doing hit this he had a joint
with no filter because that's how he
does it I hit this joint he explained it
what it was that's different he grabbed
he goes I'll see you in a little bit he
walked off like this is the smoothest fu
ever he just went here try
this remember in in Wayne's World when
they were not worthy Alice Cooper does
this that that is pie guy with like yeah
you want to try want to try some uh F1
Durban you're welcome you're welcome and
then he
levitates cuz he's got all the flavors I
love that he's so cool he's such a cool
ass dude anyway
um like I only know like one other
person that knows him and that's the guy
that's we're not that I I'm not friends
with anymore at all and he is nose bur
very well and I know my old homie I know
how he is that's why a lot of reason why
we're not homies anymore so I could only
imagine the [__] he's been saying yeah
and that fool said he just goes to the
mall and buys cookie shirts and burns
them I or something crazy you know or
something nuts I can only imagine like
that [__] [__] up yeah they cuz I
nothing has ever happened sorry
nothing's ever happened man so a dude
like that is the reason why like me and
like Jamal all my homeboys haven't
talked before or like 10 years over some
over some nonsense like that yeah it's
insane
dude so I'm G get into this so I'm G say
this right now I'm not saying this like
oh he's got to come on the show to
explain himself now that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying it and I'm sure 90
people are GNA tag you on this and shoot
me a DM dude if you want to talk about
if you don't care then don't care it's
totally cool but someone name Marty asks
me all the time we should get bur her on
here talk about it go no it's not a
therapy session we got talk about it
first in person and then if we're like
oh okay we're friends now you should
come on the show I don't want to sit
here and go therapy session well you
said that you didn't like my stuff like
that's how we're going to act each other
that and not really how we're going to
talk
but that's
like that's that's like it's just weird
there's things that need to happen for
the community just that that's why we're
talking about this today because we we
people ask us so we put a wish list he's
like number two after Joey
Diaz yeah bro people ask constantly it's
to the point where I'm like in my head
going th you just got to talk to this
fool already because it's almost awkward
that you keep avoiding the question with
for people MH because he's everybody I
talked to say he's a super nice dude I'm
a super nice dude what's the problem
also like if if you don't care I bro
same it's totally cool like if you don't
care to come here and talk about it bro
that's fine I just need to put it out in
the air because people ask so much even
Bole kev's like no no no no something's
wrong I'm what you say I'm going to put
you two together n something's wrong
here no you guys would love each other
and I went we like yeah man like it's
cool dude you don't got to
moderate you're good dude I swear to God
he's doing fine without our friendship
if he wants to like talk one day maybe
we like hit it off and go oo you like
that weed I yeah me too here check this
out all right this fool is enterprising
though I've been following his Instagram
across the why follows were heavy he Lo
like bro there's a it's a very good it's
a it's a pretty wild story that guy's
got yeah like bro I'm not a hate I'm not
a hater mhm that's all I got to say all
right here we go not a hater man so like
you could have probably told his story
you know in a different perspective than
probably any host I could have said all
of this as a hateful ass fool like well
he doesn't like me and started tweeting
at me go go tag him and say Thomas for
president or something dumb no I don't
care today we were coming out for a solo
episode and I was like you know what I
need to air this out already because
Marty's asking me every other week
whenever you feel like you want to talk
to B we should on the show like Marty
it's just going to be weird dude cuz he
don't [__] like
me that's all I say he don't like me
it's so weird to hear that like it's the
only time you I've ever heard that
anyone anyone that's ever cuz I beat
around the bush and I'm go oh we just
haven't connected I've only told he
don't like me to like four people after
like the third time they've asked me
about it BL Lake G was the second time
honestly very he don't like me bro let's
just leave it at that it's just awkward
he goes what so I'm sorry for beating
beating in the ground but here we go so
two years ago this guy on Twitter said
hok bro dopil you got to get burner in
the
podcast burner retweeted it it says he's
been hating on me for years which I
never understood and I have a
photographic memory that that tweet has
been changed since because it said I I I
mean I'm good at I know what I saw and
it says you made me for years which i'
never never understood never don't
understand never understand never
understood it don't care to
understand but now it's changed maybe I
just didn't find that tweet but of a
great memory anyway I'm screenshot and
people like damn you're screenshotting
are you trying to start beef and Dr No
this is me going after seven years going
oh that guy doesn't like me I think
that's what I think that's what the I
think it's just this one mutual friend
talking about D cuz here we go and I
wrote back
literally never said a word about you I
have three signed CDs from you when I
used to go to your shows in Santa Cruz
bought the first cookie shirt ever made
at so fresh have multiple pics with your
CDs on my Instagram before I got deleted
if this is hating then I'm a hater
that's what I
wrote and then boom he responded just
heard from some mutual friends and from
different circles you have spoken about
me a few times glad it's not the case
much love bro
oh okay I mean there's only there's only
three people that we know are the same
people I mean this is all adding
up when he said that I
went Hating Ass Mutual homie I know I
know exactly what he's saying bro cuz
I'm I'm not trying to get into it about
what he's has said because I'm not a
gossip and ass
girl I'm not trying to throw down girls
I'm talking about I'm not a gossiping
ass [__] all right I'm doing good not
cussing today I'm doing pretty good I'm
doing pretty good people will pick the
most horrible thing they can think of
and just throw it out there about you
like yeah those type of people I promise
man since 2012 to 2019 I'm not hating on
you because I don't have time all I was
cared about was hoping to make my rent
all I cared about and for those two
months when I was running cookies I
didn't have to
worry and other than that that's it oh
after that thing where we met and
they're like yo can you get me some
water like I don't work here they fired
me two days later okay that's why I was
weird I'm like is it cuz I told that
fool how much I get paid and then maybe
he told him he goes we're paying that
kid for K to run the pages fire him and
find someone cheaper that's what I
thought in my head I'm like Dam did they
fire me after they met me oh my God am I
am I a dick that's did I do something I
got fire two days later after I was
crushing it
yeah so that's why I was like oh does he
don't like or
something yeah and then all these twe
anyway his much love that's what he said
and then I this what I said I have no
friends I chill with regularly that know
you personally 100% misunderstanding or
someone we both know is a hater MH all
good I thumbs up and that was
it I just said that cuz I know exactly
what is going on I know exactly who I
don't talk to anymore who knows him very
well and I know the type of person they
are and all he did was like start a fake
awkwardness between two people that do
fun stuff
yeah yeah so yo that's it I just wanted
to throw that out there because the
tweets finally reassured be like oh yeah
something is there is an awkwardness
something is there I knew it wasn't just
me bro cuz when I'm at cups and we pass
each other I'm like
oo since that tweet or no no I haven't
been to any event since 2021 really oh
yeah yeah but you oh yeah I felt it we
had booths right across from each other
I was
like remember like
dude not
like no one's like doging me I just felt
like this should be where's the barrier
why is there a barrier between these boo
we w we all smell we sell clothes we
doing the same something's wrong what's
wrong cuz we're over here dying laughing
having fun the whole time
M why aren't we doing that together
we're right across from each other we're
in California we're both Brown
Central Valley was a shop in my town
yeah like it's kind of it's kind that's
why I was like it's kind of awkward like
what did
I what did I do and now I realize like I
didn't I didn't do anything it's it's
this full talking it has to be because I
never said any I would know if I
went all right so one time I may have I
said something to somebody I was I was
feeling this type of way I found out
that it wasn't that and cookies didn't
do that that's probably what I don't
have that story and if I did have that
story I would say it like I always say I
I think Drake is awesome when I did my
Spotify list he's my number one listen
to person oh man then it says Benny then
it says Benny under it I'm like Drake's
my number one listen to person I was
curious about that are you Ser I
screenshotted it
went my old fans are going to make fun
of me what era Drake are you listening
to like new new Drake no like the past
seven years the reason why I said that
is cuz I I used to be a drake
hater I used to be a ha I made a video
once and it was me with my headphones in
and it
was you laid it on your rent something
something something or is Drake just
murdering Spotify and it was like me
throwing my headphones off like oh it's
like try weed it was like an adill
commercial I made I was Drake just
ruining Spotify and that that was like
one of my when I was still ha I was a
hater because everybody used to say hey
Drake's the best rapper he's the best
rapper live best rapper Al and I was
like no he is not shut up now I hate him
I don't like that guy best rapper alive
he wasn't saying it the fans were yeah
how am I going to hate on something for
the love other fools have and
everybody's like nobody knew who ma Dre
was until he shouted him out in that
song I'm like did you what did you just
say to me and I started getting so mad
like he didn't say that why are you mad
at him like people hate on me all the
time shouted out your guy yeah and there
was like nobody knew who M Dre was until
Drake said I go shut
up I'm like that's not true everybody
knows that not true you're just dumb
yeah Drake didn't say that why would I
hate on Drake for something that his
fans said yeah that's the dumbest thing
and that's when I went Thomas you're a
hater and I stopped 2015 I stopped I was
like I'm a hater I got to stop hating is
the only thing I was was like very ad
like I was on it with music and with I
did not I was not a drake fan at all I
if you listen to Drake and it was your
number one guy like
oh and then I was like I got to stop
hating on him and I listen to
went this is who I've been hating
on I'm a dummy I'm so dumb and in the
future the future one came out with
Drake and Future and I've just been a
fan ever
since I'm tripping I was hating on
somebody for the love fools had for him
and what's wrong with me that's not his
fault it's yeah it's just like how dumb
of my mindset of like you're not the
you're a trash you know Deltron Del
funky Homo sapiens more lyrical than
this blah bro he's just making his own
music making stuff why are you hating on
him because people love him that much
that they say he's the greatest blah
blah blah who cares they have another
opinion of you who can't and that's when
I was like Thomas you're turning into a
hater the reason I bring this up is
because I Drake I think is awesome I
think that fool's hilarious and in the
movies I've seen him he's funny on top
of that he drop number ones non [__]
stop always he he him and Kanye West are
two of the top fools right now that can
like yeah give my roll ofex you want a
number
one that one go oh we want to feat your
number one all right got you got you
girl or boy that's Drake and I you can't
knock it hard hard as fool right now he
can do what he
wants eight years ago me saying that I
would have been like yeah yeah right you
want him on your show I used to be a
hater and that's why I talk about it
don't be a hater I used to be I used to
hate Drake and now look at me all I did
was go check yourself fool and that's
why I'm saying this the the reason I
brought up the Drake thing is if there
was a reason or a thing that I used to
hate on burner for I would have said
it nothing was not you weren't bashful
about hating on people and not even
hating speaking my mind about how I felt
about it my deep opinion but also like
not everything warrants your
opinion like people like I just State my
opinion I can't say it well leave it out
of the comments nobody cares about your
hated ass comment like uh in the comedy
world this exists with like comedians
like wanting to maybe they feel threat
jealous yeah they feel threat or they
don't want they kind of block somebody's
path when they could have helped them
out if the dude maybe helped them out in
the past and then they get on and then
they no I'm talking about comedy you
know like comedians that exists that's
why like when you're not saying about
this situation with me and B no no I was
like what the well I'm saying it exists
similar thing like exists in that world
but then when you came into this space
the first thing you did was like let's
get Goblin let's get erican let's get oh
yeah the hater thing to do would be like
no yeah like the opposite of that like
let's lift everybody up for the whole
this whole Community real quick with you
saying that there's a lot of people that
tag like up becoming Webers and all that
stuff this is the reason why we don't
have every Weber on I'm going to say
this right now cuz there's a lot of
people that tag me and stuff like you
you're slipping not having this guy on
he's up and com you should help him out
this is not the
weed content creator
podcast look we had Eric Goblin on and
and and raw OG right right off the bat
right I follow all three of those people
all three of those people have a great
story behind them they've been doing
content for years and we can there's
only a few people on Earth that I can
relate to in the in the quarrels and
dilemmas that I've had Goblin's
definitely won Eric's won Brandon's
definitely won so we had those three
content creators on and a lot of people
always hit me up like you're a hater ass
fool not getting the smaller content
creers why because it won't bring views
bro I don't know you I don't follow you
and a lot of people say well you didn't
know trap FL Ross that good he is not a
weed content creator you know how many
people I have like chilled with once or
twice and it turns out they've been
using my name to sell packs and or be
like yeah I know this fool yeah no no no
and then
they I I'm good okay I've met let me
just say this now there's some content
creators out there you guys tag me every
single day to have
on I just sometimes I don't mesh with
people all right I've met a certain
content creator and I'll leave it up to
this I don't even want to say names
because then it's just going to keep it
going keep it going I've met a certain
content creator right met him nice dude
super cool guy I'm G to say that right
now he's a very nice person I don't
think he's a bad
person but you guys tag me at 90 times a
day have a B have a
b if there's content creators of weed
that I want on here we'll hit out reach
out to them if they want to come on
they'll come on but like with the weed
content it's harder for us to have it on
because all we're going to do is sit
here and talk about what gets us Flagg
like yo so you take you took a bong RP
once yeah and a lot of people say well
ra OG just takes bong rips raw OG has
millions of fans across his alter ego
evil M and that's what inspired my ass
to go wow bro that is the coolest thing
ever you have a whole another thing we
got to get your story out there like
that how long it take it took me three
months of watching Goblin you asked over
and over you got to get Goblin on I'm
like you educated me on like cuz at
first you didn't want to at first I was
like no dude you talking about smoking
crack no bro I don't want to put that
out there and then I watch I go
oh this is like Story Time gifted story
this is sick cuz I saw like Craig
Chronicle no dude I don't want to put
that out to our fans smoking CRA no no
you didn't want to have an active user
on advocating to the fans that yes I
didn't want somebody that's actively
getting doing drugs and then one of them
old
ODS over there go play the clip over and
over and over and over and over telling
the story and US laughing at it m it
took me months of watching Goin I went
no this fo is awesome yeah he does drugs
but who cares he's awesome I like his
stuff he has a great and he tells
Amazing Stories Eric is the other
biggest weedtuber and has awesome ass
stories super and I know him he's super
smart entrepreneur that's why wanted him
on he's been doing this for years
there's other content creators that are
getting bigger that been doing this for
for a little amount of time fulc we
brought on because the
fans tagged us a million and a half
times and we had to look into it
remember how many times they say that
took I don't know man because he's just
going there smoking places out I I don't
I don't like people smoking out public
places it's kind of rude no I told you
no five times and I went Marty let me
just watch a video I watched a video go
this is the nicest kid ever I even said
like this guy seems so nice I was so big
busy and like not thinking like no we
content like we can't dude we can't just
keep we content creator cuz we're going
to get flagged we're not going to do
nothing we're going to talk about this
and then I'm like wait this guy folr is
so cool he's got this super cool message
that he's hidden in all this wild [__]
exactly he's like a little bee he's
going to get you with his Crazy lyrics
and then just get you with the
positivity at the end fulam is so cool
the second I watched the video went oh
this guy's
nice I like this and I watched like
three videos and went yeah you thought
he was on like some streamer like I
thought he was on some weird like be
rude in public smoke out mhm no not at
all but look it's going to take some
time the reason I got fulam is the only
other we content creator exception the
fans tagged us so much and Chris udala
and Chris udal well Chris udal actually
follow on Tik Tok and I think he's funny
so we're like yeah we got to get him on
but see this is the thing like we can't
just have people on like the Indie guy
what if we had the Indie guy on then a
month later he erased all his videos I'm
a cop gu's a cop now used to do we
content ask somebody to take all his
content down
anyway like we got to guard our I guess
Integrity yeah exactly we have to and
I'm not saying you oh they're not big
enough you can't come on that is never
the
case we we brought OG on brought my mom
on she doesn't do Instagram we brought
OG on against his well he knew he was
that funny so you got to remember like
we we we
just because a weedtuber gets in their
Discord and goes hey go tag dope as
usual N9 million times we got to feel it
we gotta we have to with ful like yeah I
tagged us a million times I don't care
don't care it took two months literally
bounced off us for a while for months
I'm like dude I just saw the videos him
blowing it up the only video I saw was
him yelling at that dude with a slurpie
and threw the slurp so I'm like I don't
want that Vibe and then I watch any
other video I'm like this is the nicest
dude ever so smaller content creators
like that do weed stuff you got to
remember like we we got to watch your
stuff we got to like look just because
people tag us doesn't mean you know how
many rappers have gotten tagged on [__]
a million times we've passed on number
one hit artists because we know it's not
going to mess with the fans how many
people have we passed on like that is a
massive person it's actually like it's
disgusting to think about who we've said
no to because like our fans won't care
they just they that's not our realm they
just won't mesh it's a very specific
person that that goes on this show and
we just know it that there's really no
criteria other than we just feel it make
it happen then and for everybody up and
coming like [__] that who knows that
moment happens it happens like and with
weed content you might remember we're
not the weed show we're the biggest weed
people I get it we do weed content we
smoke weed people think about it as the
weed show we've done smokeless episodes
we like we just happen to get high as
hell it's not like we're coming on here
to like
I know I'm trying to say you not the
weed show but you have weed weed
sponsors like bro you got to remember
Mario Lopez is going to come on here
we're not going to be smoking maybe
maybe but like we we we got to be able
to be that too so we can't just be here
going today we have glass blower
extraordinaire like we that's not a
crossover show than a straight up weed
podcast yeah we're not a straightup weed
show we like yeah we're like the the
crossover comedy show with heavy weed
influence thank you yeah we're here to
make you laugh also man we're talking
about drugs sometimes we smell weed on
here wow but it's not like with Eric and
Goblin we did the whole show was getting
high because they're that's what it's
about that's what they do it's what I do
it's what we do that's why we did
that you know what I'm saying dude like
this so when you we get all these people
tagging us and people get like you're
hater not bringing them on bro I need
some substance and I'm not saying they
don't have substance is not what I'm
saying oh you're smaller no we got to
care Goin had a huge following I still
took me three months of watching him it
takes a while man it t it takes a minute
sorry also back to what I was
saying but also just all relationships
and like the entertainment world it's
like a lot of times with most the guests
it's like okay well maybe now we're
aware of you maybe now in a couple
months from now we hear about you again
maybe then now we now organically that's
how things happen in the real world it's
not just always bam I want this hit it
up oh you didn't do it right away now
I'm pissed that's not how connections
happen in the real world ever barely
ever a lot of I mean the connection that
made this happen was [__] eight years
or whatever yeah like it's just about
when the time's right and if the time's
right the time's right so be it yeah but
I I'll close with this so we can wrap up
we did pretty good on the time yeah I
was going to say it I don't want to
throw into names but you know there's
there's I've I've I've met a lot of
content creators I've met a lot of we
tubers I've met a lot of people nobody
I've met is is jerk like nobody's a jerk
like I said this person I think is a
nice person it just doesn't mesh I don't
care doesn't mesh with me it doesn't
work all right so I met the guy nice
dude made a video super cool nice
guy then he invited me to do a shoot I
went over
there and it was supposed to be like a
weed selling shoot and I was like yeah
that's
cool and then right when I got there I'm
like I brought two pounds of OG just
just in case we need some stuff and I
get there I'm like where's the weed like
oh we were hoping you brought weed so in
my I'm like bro so if I didn't bring
these like the whole shoot's gone damn
come on man you got to let me
know what's wrong man you should have
told me who cares who cares that's not a
big deal I thought it was funny like
damn I'm I brought these anyway we're
doing a picture and it's like me this
influencer dude and another guy and I
have two pounds right and he's like
let's take a picture with the with the
pounds like a picture I'm like all right
that's cool and this is what look at I'm
very observant I observe every you know
how like they did this and said that and
then he threw his [__] on the ground
looked at it didn't even pick it
up I don't know about that guy yeah
there's very little there there's small
there's small stuff oh there's small
stuff dude little Flags [__]
yes so we're sitting there and I'm like
yeah what do you want to do the picture
he goes how about like you guys sit
close to me and we'll grab the pounds
like take a picture you know just look
at the camera like all right cool and he
just does this grabs the P grabs the
weed and puts it on his head and like
leans forward I'm
like do you want to send the picture
bro like you just like basically did
this like do you want do you want to
take a picture by
yourself what is happening here like do
you want me in this picture just like
this in the back why'd you get like it
was just awkward it was more like P did
he all up in the video feeling I was
like
yo why am I this is kind of a I just F I
thought it was kind of awkward
like
like I don't know I don't I'm trying to
explain it it was it was very who here
can sing I can no he can't I can sing
like damn bro I you want to be the star
of the show but maybe bring some weed
next time to your own
shoot weird anyway uh we did it and I
was just in my head I'm like damn you
really wanted to be the center of that
picture that was very awkward like I
even looked at the other dude the other
dude looked at me like uh
so I was like okay so it wasn't just me
it was kind of awkward right all right
cool not a big deal I just thought it
was very like noticing things damn
F GE I'm trying to think if I'm trying
to think of it like remember when in in
family matters when Eddie winsell starts
that band and he's like wants to be the
star and they all get pissed cuz he
shuns them all like I'm the star that's
how I felt I was like
whoa I get you want to be like the
center of the attention but like there's
three FS you're going to do this and
you're just blocking us why don't you
just take the picture by yourself I just
thought it was very
like pretty girl weird I just thought it
was kind of awkward I was like slightly
belittling not not belittling just more
of
like oh he really loves the camera huh
he it's okay I'm like totally totally
okay you know what not be lling but just
like oh you you love you want okay
that's cool but okay it's no big deal
it's fine more just extra than anything
yeah they just be a little extra but
that's not a big deal I just noticed it
and I was like uh it's okay you know I
know some Hollywood kind of fools he's
not a Hollywood dude like he's a a Weber
but I'm like oh it's cool who cares and
then
um one time he's like yo you want to
smoke I'm like yeah that's cool come by
he's like yeah we film like a bong
hitter or
whatever like smoking I'm like all right
cool and I I I said yeah but I felt
awkward like he came to my house and
like I don't know he just had like a
list of questions and was just like
filming me in my house which is fine
like we made content but I was I felt so
awkward I was just
like you've never not had a camera when
we hang out bro like if you want to just
like hang out like that's
cool hell of times Goblin and erican and
them come over and nothing's getting
filmed get filmed yeah like you want to
hang about it's like this like like feel
like the first time we really just hung
out I thought we were just going to
chill but it's it's okay it's like it's
okay I thought we were just going to
chill like you and Fil A bong hater or
whatever but
like I didn't know we're going to like
do an interview right here it's cool
though it's cool it's just the way he
was saying like it's it's the thing it's
like you edited that and put it out the
next morning like you really and with a
crazy ass like fish bait clickbait title
was
like oh bro just come to my house and
try to use me for some VI right now that
was weird I just thought it was kind of
awkward still I was like you know you
like to be up in the
video put my [__] on your on your
channel that's totally cool all good but
like we the we filmed the whole time he
was there I was It was kind of weird I
can't talk about stuff when we're on
camera like we can't just there people
most my homies talking about illegal
things like we can't just be we're like
in film mode the whole time I thought we
were just smoking but it's all totally
cool you know what I mean like it's
still all good vloggers Vlog yeah they
Vlog they do their thing I get
it it's fine they hit me up like the
next morning and was
like yo you want to do a video with me I
want to charge these companies and like
you know we can just make this video and
put it on your channel and we'll charge
this company in the back of my head I'm
like are you da King ass fool what are
you trying to do like you just want me
to
like so what you're saying is you want
to use my name to go ask a person to pay
you and then put it on my channel so I
can put you on my channel featuring you
and the that's a great deal for him
great deal yeah super
sick and the way he was saying I think
we can get 5K out of it I'm
like you charge this little company five
bands a [__] that's dumb cuz the idea he
had was like that's taxing that's not
even like worth a video that's stupid
that's just saying like well we have the
you know dope jeles in it and me like we
have a big following combin cuz he even
said like combined followers that
warrants this I'm like bro are you just
really trying to use me to make money I
don't like this I like I don't I don't
know about this and I kind of like went
like this for a
second right yeah I just kind of put the
brakes on it a little
bit and then he came over one more time
we were talking and then I was talking
about videos it's the first time I
really got age restricted and he's like
oh yeah blah blah blah start talking he
goes you know what I do is I go I type
in like blunt smoke or how to roll a
blunt or I'll type in weed and I'll go
through the top viewed video and then
I'll just make that I went what he goes
yeah like I'll go and like I I'll make
the thumbnail similar I'll do almost the
same title featuring you know my
name and then I'll just make the same
video
and in my head I'm like I'm never
hanging out with this guy again in my
head I was like it's the last time I
chill with you and out went oh oh oh you
mean like like just copy it he goes yeah
like if it's got hella views people are
already looking for
that I was like what what I was like oh
okay I yeah I guess so I never I never
thought about that I said it almost like
oh wow good idea but all my have the top
views like
what you're just you're just not even
thinking you're just copying
people it's like having a ghost riter
yeah I was like you know what it's okay
but in my head I'm
like we have never hung out without a
camera I don't like this
friendship that's all that's all I felt
about like I don't know if I like this
this
this I don't like this feeling I feel
corny yeah that's all I just made me
feel corny yeah and then um
what happened is uh this guy posted a
video with my exact title and thumbnail
and did not know that it was my video I
guess you just screenshoted it and then
did the same thing and I and I posted
like wow pretty similar i f erase the
whole video and ever since then he is
just we just he's just like not happy
with me like I could tell like because I
follow this person and then I went to
look at him on Twitter one day one Tak I
was like wait did we do that I was like
no there's no there's no way and I went
on there I'm like there's no way this
just caught me I was already blocked I
was like this V blocked
me oh [__] all right all right you
blocked me okay I was just calling you
out a little bit but it's all
right it's okay and then and then
somebody tagged me on something like
well I thought I was blocked like months
later I went oh I'm not blocked anymore
huh but it's once again going oh I I
forgot about you existed [__] I went on
with my life because that's that's what
I do why I'm not and then
um what happened I was I was curious
about something because I was releasing
a paper and I'm like somebody's like
this Fool's released in I'm like
what the day after I released my weird
and I was like oh I'm blocked again D
you know what I was like you know what
man do your thing bro I'm good like it's
totally
okay in my head I was like oh yeah I
don't know if I can I don't know feels
very very trender trendy dick riding I
think I need to get away but it's okay
like nice person do your thing not
everybody needs to be friends and
collaborate to do like it's it is okay
do your
thing I just don't care enough to be
like let's squash it squash what nothing
on my end
man I'm good dude I'm just good I don't
I feel dis I don't feel genuine yeah
that's all I just don't feel genuine
when I'm around you and that's okay just
that's what we go by yeah I just don't
and that's all right maybe you don't
feel like that about me I know a
comedian that uh comes up with a new
identity he you know like every one day
we will get into that story whatever it
[__] feels like it one day we will
get into that story talk about searching
videos to just remake what works talk
about taking on a whole new
identity talk no I can't say it we'll
save that yeah we'll save that one that
little rocket That's funny though yeah
but hold on I'm
sorry keemstar do your thing man but
also that's wild it it was a wild story
it's a wild story yeah yeah and then
what we what else we we got on to like
we're usually so positive and I think
all of these ended in positivity yeah I
mean like no matter what no matter what
story we talked about it was positive
mhm you know like it was yeah like start
you know man I was in a dark place I had
to let let it go because you know I just
had to let it go CU I had to move on my
life and throw my life away because you
did something that
I if somebody scratches Rosie I'm
waiting outside their house too yeah
someone hit oh it's
over as I'm sitting there going oh my
God prison's GNA suck I'm sitting there
going throwing it away throwing it away
you know what I'm going to hire somebody
to do this and I'm going to get up and
go I'm out of here man that's what I'm
going to do go no I'm I think I'm good I
don't want can you film it for me on a
trap phone and then throw the phone away
after that's that that'd be me so I get
you I would be waiting outside too
totally get it then we moved on to the
thing I had to talk about because you
guys asked so much maybe burner will be
here one day yo man I hope you listen to
all of it I hope you probably didn't if
you did hear it you should listen to it
because if I get a DM and it's anything
negative you did not listen to this
whole thing because nothing is wrong
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
there's no
there's no be it's just awkward because
we don't know the answer of why we're
both
like you're a veteran Super Fan
basically from back in the day like
mixtape era [__] you just need to
straighten this [__] out gra I gave the
cookie shirt about two years ago to my
cousin Adrian the first one cuz this is
after I got those tweets I was like you
know what man not giving the CDs away
cuz they're Priceless to me I don't want
this shirt anymore I'm not going to rock
it I can't rock it obviously something's
wrong nobody wants to fix that so I
think I I feel weird repping something
that I'm like oh connection to this this
guy hates me sick yeah that's why I
always tell you like I don't want a fan
to hate me and every time they look at a
shirt go I hate this guy God I got a
closet full of guy I hate you know what
I mean like totally and I'm not saying I
hate the guy I'm not saying I was like I
feel weird wearing it it's like cuz then
people cuz you got to remember I'm I'm a
person that does the weed a lot of
people follow me they see me wearing the
shirt go oh oh you guys must be homies
like actually your opinion says a lot
yeah exactly it it it be sound cool guy
but it it does and people will bring it
up like why don't you do a podcast and
bug me and bug me and bug me about it
because they see me with a shirt or they
see me rocking a hoodie and go oh he
must know him he must be chill but if I
didn't wear it like a bunch of people
it's just a mystery that thousands of
people DM me how come we never do
anything with bur I always wondered you
never do nothing with cookies every time
every time it's it's on my question it's
always in my videos you'll see it in the
in the comments I get the DMS daily why
don't you ever I always wondered is
something wrong and when he posted that
hell of people I knew there was a reason
he was never on his YouTube I knew there
was a reason he never did that by the
way shout out to the fans because in
that tweet it was nothing but people
supporting me MH like a bunch of people
that do music like I know Thomas and
something is obviously wrong yeah you
know literally DJ after thought one of
the nicest guys I've ever met
something's wrong here even Q the Earth
Gang manager M Miller manager's like
Thomas is awesome something went wrong
here I saw the tweets I'm like yeah you
guys got my back because like thank you
for having my back yeah cuz I just look
like a liar defending yourself against
being a like a hater for no reason
basically CU in in anyone else's eyes
like yeah right like if you knew how
genuinely genuine all these people
backing me up are yeah CU you know them
because they all know they all know him
too so it's like oh thank you guys man
anyway we went through that and then we
went through
plug in whoever you want to plug in
don't care enough to say the name but
there's you know there's a YouTuber you
guys ask for all the time I'm just good
man just so you don't think he's not
listening like yeah I listen I see you
guys commented 50 time I'm just kid we
talk about this every day we're talking
about Guest booking every day every day
and how many times you bring people up
got to be
honest that guy's kind of a jerk or or
the guy we're talking about I
go I just how am I going to get through
that so
how you come with your got good episode
too yeah like it can't be me doing that
like every episode we put out is like
important to us we want it to be as it
can be so it'd be awkward for me forcing
it you know so that's why we haven't had
if there's other we tubers we're going
to have on well you'll see them on here
but as of right now we've had like all
the biggest ones up if you think about
it all the biggest ones
on yeah that's it so guys thank you for
being here we appreciate two two hours
that was a long story took a long time
but it's a lot of
backstory and uh yeah thank you guys for
being here we appreciate you um anything
else
Marty happy birthday
April let's see no as this comes out
it's going to be oh the Monday I was
like dude what yeah what what what what
yes she shares a birthday with
[__]
Jay-Z
December 4th a child was get out of here
that's why I married her man she got
stabbed the Jay-Z connection
oal get out look how Mari you know like
when when birds are like yo look at my
my colors and Feathers just [__] just
know if you ever meet a Kim named cim
O'Neal you just got to take one to the
arm and he's yours forever because if
there's anything like his dad here he's
very easily ghetto impressed like yo she
got stabbed dog I know she she's down
for me then if she got stabbed hell
spiders in the hallway and [__] this
grind here
godamn barely walk up this [__] hole
barely walk in there man it's going to
be my wife her house is
scary yo what's wrong with you it's
crazy to think about it um oh yeah to
everyone out
there there's no problems nobody's got
no problem right that's all you know we
don't got any [__] problem no nobody
cares nobody cares enough to have a
problem we just thought it was it's
enough if you watch this story anybody
that ever asked like you should have the
podcast I'm just going to give you the
link to this like yo watch this episode
watch this episode it's the only reason
why he hasn't been on here if he's going
to be on here he's G to be on here he's
not he's not totally cool I promise guys
that's it like like was it
Samson and Half Baked that's how I
feel please stop taging me every day
like I promise I was a fan too man it
doesn't
help all right just like LRG it's like I
was a super fan of
LRG it's just so weird like yo it's so
dumb like this shouldn't be it shouldn't
be that way anyway um also guys once
again thank you for being here uh leave
a like support the channel we appreciate
you support the clips Channel dop usual
podcast Clips cuz there's definitely
going to be nine Clips out of this one
um there was a dad on an LRG shirt at
the [__] soccer game today and I
[__] my head you punched
him and I just murdered
him you know that thing or I told you my
dad walked behind my step brothers and
he just ripped their shirt by the seam I
don't know about that he walk up cuz he
used to wear huge white te's my dad's
like you look at gang bang you guys are
not tough I don't like when you wear
these shirts I never rock that I'm not
dumb and this seam right here okay if
you grab here and you grab here walk
behind
somebody you can RI and it rips all the
way down the shirt and the shirt just
slides right off like a hospital ground
yes exactly my dad used to do it to my
Step Brothers all the time on the way to
the store he ain't wearing that [__]
walk with me the store
disrespectful and then he did it to me
once and I lost it on had a vam shirt on
a
wellmade like a shirt that fits it was a
blue VC I remember I bought it it was
$24.99 I was like damn $25 by a shirt
took him a couple [__] rips no he did
it and then it didn't even rip and it
just stretched over my shoulder and I
was pissed I yelled at I was he was all
drunk I was pissed anyway that's a trend
now oh I know the [__] Eagles did it
to Josh Allen they Ain call it last week
[__]
[__] was hanging
off that is not what it is that's not
what that is man yeah the Eagles did the
Josh Allen you had that [__] locked and
loaded man the internet was pissed we
were all pissed I saw the picture I was
like yeah that's not a horse callar but
it should be um but yeah there we go
guys thank you so much for being here we
have uh ranted long time thank you for
helping us thank you for being here
thank you for watching the show thank
you for supporting go to to dope asusual
podcast.com the clothes are on sale
right now all the shirts as soon as
we're sold out of everything we're going
to be do something completely different
with the merch we're try something else
we're getting a new Warehouse we're
moving out of this place very odd but
we're finally leaving all right after 3
years at the warehouse we're finally
leaving guys I think we found a push
tre's house I mean push tre's house
push's
warehouse it made me feel weird thinking
that we're not going to be
at the push trees spot with the where it
made me feel
weird so it made me rethink last night
remember I talked to you yesterday after
that conversation I thought of I don't
want to not I don't I don't want that I
don't want
to go to the push trees whereare I go
wow it's nice in here I haven't been
here in six months yeah because why
would I need to be there get the samples
and leave so it's it's it's really nice
being able to give the guests like have
them see that it's even bigger than the
podast too like oh you guys got a whole
set like what oh you got a whole brand
coming out of here that has nothing to
do with podcast thanks for all the gifts
that's cool not I mean obviously we
could still do that yeah no we can it's
just it's just odd knowing like this
place is only for filming mhm yeah like
here it's like a like a stage it's like
a like a set yeah here oh you're in this
world oh you're in this world now you're
back in this world if it was less
expensive and just a little cleaner on
the outside yeah this place sucks I
can't oh we're going to tear this wall
down because it's a f F wall behind
Marty this this this this is a fake wall
there's a window and a door behind this
wall and on the other side is the season
one set the huge set is on the other
side of this wall two big fake walls
yeah so what we're going to do is we're
going to cut this out and I'm going to
frame that we're going to cut out
whatever you want and then what we're
going to do is we're going to rip the
walls down we're going to stay leave it
right outside drop you guys the address
when we leave please come grab a piece
of the set if you're a fan and you're in
LA or you're a fan you know somebody
that another spot come grab a piece of
the set we're going to that's what we're
going to do legitimately crazy that's
[__] weird and whatever's gone the ne
not there the next day I mean whatever's
left over we'll get the trash guys to
come and take M but I want you guys to
come take a piece of the set I think
that would be insane to get pictures and
people have a piece of our set in their
house just a smiley face you know saying
man like that's that's it's insane dude
to think about
makes me sad kind
of yeah but ultimately we want to have a
cooler cleaner better look we want some
depth I want to be 8T away from this
wall so we can highlight the wall like
season one that was the big Advantage we
had with that set yeah a little bit more
room this room's like a tight rectangle
mhm all right sorry to bore you guys Man
by but that's we're we're we're doing
right now we're actively moving so thank
you guys for being here from Marty and I
guys this has been a long episode all
ending on positivity I hope it's all
good nothing's wrong nothing is wrong
it's all just misunderstandings except
for Slappy scratchy hands that's
different Slappy scratchy hands is a
whole different story all right oh no no
you we're talking about leaving on
positivity now this guy's going to go
all right at least Marty's got that guy
sto it stoic mad at me that guy that's
he's GNA say the guy stoic from the
gangster remember
that's who Marty is and go oh man he
just gun clicked me hey man soundboards
these days that soundboard was supposed
to be yeah a cheerful and he did that
this is not a threat no sorry I meant to
[__] hit
uh
right that's creepy I don't like that
guys um this is all supposed to be
positive all positive thank you so much
for being here from Mario Neil and I
this has been the dope as usual podcast
we're here to talk about life drugs
problems problems misunderstandings
awkwardness sleeping outside setting
fools up for DJ spots so he can beat
them up and misunderstandings with other
people that do really fun weed stuff
right all right and I don't want to work
with every weed tuber man I talk to a
lot I'm not saying I'm not saying if
I've met you before like is he talking
about me that he doesn't like to talk
man I barely collab with anybody
only had two collabs I think in my whole
entire existence I like making videos at
home by myself like it's hard man but
what I'm saying is for the podcast just
because people make we content doesn't
mean like it's our responsibility to
like have to sit here and talk about
like bro if we want to talk we want to
talk I'm sorry like there's not much
more to say like I said if you've seen
the list of people we say no to you
would be think first a we're lying and
two were dumb once you find out we're
not lying like did you really turn her
like yes it's not going to mesh she's
got 11 million followers not going to
mesh they're not going to give a [__] no
fans don't care you know why cuz they
don't care about
that yeah dude we've had a lot of a lot
of people a whole list a stretch a
stretch
also I'll just say it now Larry June and
logic both passed on the podcast it's
okay it's okay we're not haters still do
your thing I still listen Larry Jun was
my number before listen to all year he
told us no months ago a pass is
temporary in my eyes too a pass is just
you haven't seen the show yet all right
yeah yeah a passes we'll Circle back
pass for now all good and look at not
hating on you just because you said no
we still liked you still like you now
just want to say we would love to have
you on be super sick logic also Larry
June it'd be super awesome if you came
on the show because I love your music
and I think we can get get real high you
can talk about random ass things and we
talk about entrepreneurial
things and then we'll race our cars
after you're gonna win but here we go I
got my car back yesterday I'm so excited
all right guys that's it that's it we
just want to talk to you because you
guys ask us about logic all the time
Larry June constantly because I use him
in every video constantly using his
music you should get him on the show
yeah yeah we will I don't want be like
he said no if you guys are asking for
him we're killing ourselves to try to
get him on the show Believe yes yes we
know you want Mexican OT on the show
you're supposed to be on it's been like
3 months we're not going to sit here and
pressure and bug people go please man
whenever he wants to be on the show come
on the show and talk come get a high
with us and talk about let's talk about
Rugrats and Doug or something um all
right Marty let's get out of here thank
you guys so much for being here this has
been the dope as usual podcast from
Marty O'Neal and I have a dope ass
day damn that was a clean
out hash holes man smooth land
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]